[Music]
three times
this is
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're kicking off a new season of the
Champions chess tour with a new format
and new people in the studio we can
promise you even more action more time
travel and more of the best chess
players in the world so it's a big
pleasure to welcome all of you to the
very first day of the air things Masters
practice really looking happy with
himself the king can't move wait wait
wait wait wait this move is breaking the
rules
oh no way this just looks glorious
there we go the other lunch continues
there's a big threat on the board Magnus
Carlton is furious it's going straight
for the kill Wesley so has blundered
he's blinded his Knight the white king
is trapped this is my is Carlson showing
his genius
and more details it's incoming and this
group of Chess experts will be here
every move of the way to guide you
safely through the air things monsters
for my right Grandmaster David Howell
International Master Tanya and
Grandmaster Roberts all the way from the
US a big welcome to the awful Studio
Robert thank you guys it's your pleasure
to be here and what an exciting day for
the first time Champions chess for now
on chess.com how excited are you it's
great to have the Chess World unified
all the best players taking part in the
same tournament couldn't be more
exciting as he mentions David chess24
and chess.com now unified to create this
one massive tour for online chess this
is a big day for chess it's a big day
for everyone for the fans of the for the
players for everyone at home but as you
say it's the biggest for chess itself we
want to grow the game and the players
we've amassed world-class players here
it's going to be an exciting week and
Tanya with the new Champions chess tour
of format what can the fans expect it's
going to be so much fun Kaia we've got a
fresh mix of players the format promises
to have twists and turns dramatic stuff
so expect the unexpected
the third season of the Champions
Chester introduces a whole new format
and by the end of the year we will have
an Undisputed champion
the Champions Chester is back with more
incredible chess two million dollars in
prizes the biggest online price fund
ever and a thrilling brand new format
the 2023 tour begins with six elite
events taking place between February and
September each event features an open
qualification system with qualifiers and
players looking in 56 players to the
main events where they will be grouped
into three divisions and compete for 235
000 in prizes
victory in the first division in any of
the six events will secure a spot in the
eight players Champions chess tour
playoffs in December
players will also accumulate Tour
leaderboard points across the six events
and another hundred thousand dollars in
prize money and the unsecured playoff
spots will go to the top leaderboard
finishers
at the end of the year we have 17 days
of incredible chess beginning with the
playoffs from which just four players
will advance to the Champions chess tour
finals a single elimination bracket
together the playoffs and finals feature
500 000.
there can only be one in December of
2023 an indisputable tour Champion will
be crowned let the games begin
we can't let the games begin without
introducing our fourth expert in the
studio International Master Ivanka
houska now in the corner to keep control
of everything going on yeah this is
going to be my home for the next five
days I'm gonna keep everyone updated on
everything that's going on and the first
update we have to give everyone is the
eight players we will follow in the
first division this week this is the
lineup for the air things Masters first
division eight players they are spread
out across the world sitting in many
different time zones and looking at this
Ivanka who do you hold as the big
favorites so three colossal names just
pop out you have Magnus Carlson who is
just the boss in this kind of format
then we have Hikaru Nakamura he is the
best in online chess and of course let's
not forget Wesley so who has looked on
the tour absolutely Unstoppable at times
and there is also three teenagers in
that pack the youngest gukesh at only 16
years old what chances do you give the
young Indian yeah you know on paper he's
gonna have a tough battle because he is
facing Hikaru Nakamura but don't write
him off because he's just 16 years old
and he was the one who actually finished
first in the play-ins won six games Drew
three and knocked out the Titan that is
a World Champ former world champion
Vladimir kramnik fantastic and he has a
tough start though playing at night in
India and he starts off against the card
back of my own self I mean it's tough
but you know this is the baptism of fire
and at least you know he can relax
because of the double elimination format
he can just enjoy his moment in the
spotlight and entertain us with some
brilliant chess yep that's what's going
to happen you guys now two players were
invited to the air things Masters Magnus
Carlsen for winning the Champions
Chester 2022 and Wesley so for winning
the global Chess Championship everyone
else had to qualify
this is the air things Masters the first
event of the 2023 Champions test tour
000 in prizes are on the line as well as
a spot in the tour playoffs the air
things Masters began with a play in
Swiss tournament open to all Grand
Masters the top finishers battled in
match pay to determine who plays in
division one with eight players division
two with 16 players and division 3 with
32 players 54 qualifiers through the
play-in that was held February 3rd
during the 2022 Champions chess tour
winner Magnus Carlson and the global
chess champion Wesley so who are seeded
into division one of the air things
Masters the main event takes place
February 6th through 10th and features a
dramatic double elimination knockout
format
the winner of division one secures a
spot in the Champions chess tour
playoffs in December they will be joined
by the second and third place finishes
of division one as well as the winner of
division two into event two of the
Champions chess tour top division the
Champions chess tour is the biggest
online chess event ever held and it all
starts now with the air things Masters
we will mostly follow a division one
this week in the air things monsters but
there are some huge names actually also
competing in division three and in
division two these are today's round of
matches and look at that David John the
ponyach is in their Fabiano Corona how
did they end up in division two yeah
some huge names you mentioned to their
Jana punishi and Fabiano uh caruana
there's also Vladimir kramnik a former
world champion and those three
specifically they fell at the final
hurdle of the players they did lose the
playoffs they failed to make it to
division one that just shows how strong
how stacked this whole field is and they
will be aiming of course to qualify for
division one next time yeah and and we
have to mention Robert it's a big deal
to compete in division two as well a lot
at stake yeah ten thousand dollars first
place prize they're also a great number
of tour points at stake because the
winners of each division one they make
it through to the playoffs in December
but sort of the lead leaderboard all
right so you have to pay attention to
that exactly now in all three division
double elimination is the format which
basically means that anyone can lose a
match and still win the whole event but
the second you lose a second match you
are knocked out and this is the bracket
for the first Division and we see the
quarterfinal matchups to the left on the
screen here but Tanya who does the
double elimination format favor okay
with double eliminations it is two
strikes and you're out you've got two
shots at the championship what that does
is it takes away the luck Factor it
seems to favor the player who is truly
the best so the best player has the best
shot at winning the championship uh take
a look at this Magnuson Hikaru the two
big favorites it's hard enough to
imagine them losing one match here
you've got to knock them out twice to
have a shorter Championship yeah that's
gonna be tough but having this extra
life that Tanya says Robert does it
invite for some more risk-taking do you
think it certainly does because when you
see the field if you lose it best of
four match you drop down to the losers
bracket with best of two so you may take
those risks when you would need to in
order to stay in this field so I do
think we're going to see very energetic
and exciting play all right you guys so
we have qualification we have double
elimination we have a new time control
with 15 minutes plus only three seconds
increment we checked in wait some of the
top players to hear what they think
about the new Champions chest War
formats I think the tour last year was
was great in the sense that we had so
many young players who got the chance
but now we get all the top players as
well as the as the young players which
is uh which I think will be super
exciting at the same time the
competition is gonna be tougher because
Magnus Carlton can be playing basically
in all events and also Hitler nakamura's
there
last fight I think even for the topless
it won't be easy and there's gonna be
lots of qualifiers those sorts of
Divisions I think that's also a really
good news for the
um subtop chess players failure forcing
it to be whoever the best player wins
yeah also for me it's completely new to
play double elimination like I never
tried that and
um I always thought like if you get
eliminated you're eliminated and now
you're back again it's a little bit a
little bit weird in terms of time
control I think it's a great time
control now the games are a little bit
a little bit faster oh a lot more drama
I guess
um it's still fortunately there's some
increments so you won't see like super
nasty flagging of opponents especially
for a player like me who's
gotten a bit slower over the years in
the past of nine controls those 10
seconds were good to have plus three
seconds it's just gonna be like time
travel all the way so I guess more
players more drama more excitement for
the fans
and the action is about to start
everyone with four big quarter-final
matchups in three and a half minutes the
air things monsters will start and uh
today's matchups are some big ones
Hikaru Nakamura he's a beast at online
chess and he plays today against a
surprise winner of the qualifiers 16
year old yukash and then the winner of
the 2022 Global Chess Championship
Wesley so against Ralph mamadol and then
the big battle between the teenagers
both at 19 years old Ali reserv Russia
and Arjun ergice but we will follow the
first game
between the reigning Champions chess
tour winner Magnus Carlsen against a
debutant on the tour Alexa Serana and
David who is this guy what is his
strengths Alexa Serrata Serana is Young
and dangerous he's 23 years old he can
beat anyone on his day he's especially
good with the white pieces he's very
well prepared he can play all sorts of
positions and if you get give him a
chance to attack he will go for you the
last time these two faced each other
Serana did take the win he must be
coming in with confidence so the last
time they played Serana actually beat
Magnus Carlsen what happened there Tanya
it was like the world Blitz championship
and it was a win not just the result the
quality of the game Super convincing win
and that's just half the story Alexi
Serrano before taking down the world
champion also beating karunakamura also
be done you'll do both a very dangerous
opponent today for Magnus I actually
heard you before the show Robert you
call him the upset King is that what
Alexis Serrata is all about just
offsetting the big gear guns well he
upsets the people that he beats that's
for sure but he's also underestimated by
the public he is not quite 2700 in fide
classical rating but he has beaten the
likes of vidit Gujarati and chakra
mamajoro in lengthy matches in the
chesla comp Global Championship so with
the names that Tanya mentioned as well
he has who's who of names at his uh
victim list yeah and if you do look at
the head-to-head stats though there is
no doubt Magnus Carlsen is a favorite a
32 years old today against the 23 year
old Alexey serrana ranked as number 70
in the world Magnus Carlsen still world
number one so what is it about for
Serana today to be able to win a match
over four rapid games against Magnus
Carlsen well I feel that Alexei Serrano
he has to start off well we know that
Magnus has been guilty from time to time
of starting slowly Magnus offer needs a
bit of time to feel his way into the
into the competition he mentions he's
getting a bit older now the new time
format he might need some time to adapt
Serana is on fire he played so well in
those plays so I feel the first two
games are critical for him yeah and only
45 seconds until they played the very
first game of the 2023 Champions chess
tour season it must be a special feeling
to start off the season the very first
game you know black papers you know
anything can happen what do you expect
from Magnus with the white pieces in the
first game
come forward to see what he brings in
the opening we've seen Magnus try out
these absolutely crazy openings offbeat
stuff previously in the Champions
Chester but will he take that chance
against a player like Alexi Serrano
who's so well prepared and it just might
be the strategy that he's looking at now
Serana is known to be a doctored Edition
with the white pieces his prep is second
to none I'm actually expecting Magnus to
blow out an opening surprise in this one
really do you agree Robert I think so
because Serana is that well prepared
catch him off guard that might be the
strategy and what could that be what
would the catching him off guard mean
David it could mean anything for Magnus
Carlson I don't think we'll see
something like the bomb cloud or one F3
you know openings that he's experimented
with on the tour but uh something early
that will get to Serana out sir thinking
on his own just uh maybe a different
Pawn structure and Magnus does start
this quarterfinal with the white pieces
I think that is huge for him we
mentioned Serana is uh blisteringly good
with white so it does feel like Magnus
rolls today sometimes I think the first
few moves will be quite classical quite
normal and the surprises will start a
bit after that and we see Magnus Carlsen
is ready in his secret lab chair not
sitting in at home in Oslo he is uh as I
hear rumors visiting a friend in Canada
the chess bras well known to the public
of course and well they've been posting
on Instagram so I feel like we can let
that surprise you I agree yeah so he's
actually playing from Canada Magnus
Carlsen quite early in the morning for
the world number one getting ready for a
game number one so remember it is best
out of four rapid games to decide each
of these matches if they are tied after
those four rapid games then we will head
straight to Armageddon tie breaks to
decide who goes through to tomorrow's
winners semi-finals and who is knocked
down to the losers bracket
and a big smile on Magnus calls in space
if that area Council that we see
so he's got a support ER in the
background Eric Hansen is not playing in
any of the divisions uh is he no not
that I know of I'm not sure if he played
in the planes Eric Hansen but either way
uh Magnus this is the first time we've
seen him arrive early for a game on the
tour in ages so it's good to know he's
got his tech support with him
for a cheerleader all on board I think
it's a really crucial Point how rested
Magnus is for this first game he's
traveled over the weekend he's in Canada
right now we also saw him at the end of
Tata steel he looked absolutely spent so
it's going to be a lot about recovery
and energy yeah how would you say that
Magnus Carlson's formats we've seen him
in the rapid and Blitz World
Championship of lately and in the total
seal he was on a tear at the end of time
to steal he struggled in some of the
earlier rounds he lost two games in a
row unexpected from the world champion
but at the end when he needed his best
form he found it that's scary news for
Alexis Serrano yeah but this is rapid
the chess and it is a faster time
control that we have been used to the
two first season of the champion this
chat store so we have had 15 minutes
plus 10 seconds increment this year is
only three seconds increment and how big
of a difference is that David that's
huge there's far less margin for error
with the 10 second increment you can
kind of lose your orientation uh in the
position just for a few seconds and kind
of recompose yourself this one is purely
about Instinct three second increment
disappears so fast and we will see some
uh kind of real calamities on the
chessboard once the players tick down on
the clock so um yeah it will be about
who adapts first and it might favor
actually those who played in those plays
like Serana Magnus he's coming to this
fresh his last games were at Tata steel
seven hour time control very very
different uh type of game there and I'm
expecting Magnus to be okay he's very
experienced online of course as well but
uh Serana maybe that's something he can
play on the clock and the matches should
have started obviously some technical
issues here to get the 2023 season
kicked off we do not have an image of
Alexei Serrata but he should have
arrived and should be ready to kick off
the season with a match against Magnus
Carlton do you think this is big for
Alexa uh Tanya to play Not only a game
but a match for games against Magnus
huge opportunity for Alexa in the
Champions Chester it is his debut in the
tour it is a platform that he hasn't had
the chance to Showcase his results in in
the playoffs he beat Fabiano caruana and
what a match that was he was he had to
win on demand and then beat him in the
Armageddon and as David you were
mentioning having that practice in to
stop the first round where often things
can be shaky I think this matchup has
huge potential for an upset we also look
at well the price fund of the Champions
Chester now for players like Magnus and
Hikaru whatever that means it's 100x for
a player like Serana the financial
support we've seen breakout moments for
this teenagers on the Champions chess
store now whether it was Prague whether
it was Arjun in the previous editions
you know these are the moments that
these players are waiting for and it
could be Serrano's day today yeah we've
seen huge moments where as you mentioned
yukash pragnananda beating Magnus on the
tour would it be a huge deal for Alexa
today to to win the match against Magnus
it certainly would be and let's say he
does have some accolades to his name he
won the European online Championship
back in 2020 uh he beat Anish giri and
David Navarra in that tournament he
knocked them out of the bracket so it's
not like he's incapable of taking down
Magnus Carlsen it's just a Herculean
task for him so Alexei great success in
the past this would be his lifetime
achievement yeah
and we are waiting for the first game to
start hopefully minus Carlsen with the
white pieces we'll make his first move
very soon you guys are hinting that we
could maybe see some surprises should we
have a little bit of a bet what opening
move do you think we'll see on the board
I think Magnus will stick to something
he knows and trusts I suggest one E4 how
about you guys that's
24 David playing safety
Taco with 1v3 oh okay I'm gonna go with
the Catalan I think Magnus Carlson use
it to success in the world championship
why not again here in the Champions
chess Tour all right what about you yeah
all right all right you said I said one
E4 okay so I'll go on D4
let's see and it looks like now Magnus
Carlsen is leaning towards the screen
does that mean he is getting ready to
make that first move
or is there still some technical issues
and while we wait I should mention that
these two just uh kind of unofficially
online just in some friendly games they
have had very long matches I remember
once staying up till 2 3 A.M in the
morning watching Magnus play Serana I
think they played nearly 100 games in
that one session and it was all so
Magnus could try and adopt sir he did
succeed eventually at like 4am in the
morning but uh it just shows how much
these two love chess and how practiced
they are in the art of online chess and
if we do have anyone new to chess
watching adopting in chess what's that
mean that means winning 10 games in a
row so impressive stuff I think that was
bullet chess very different than this of
course but uh yeah so Ronald did get
some knocks into he did get some wins
under his belt in that one fantastic
all right uh let's hope the first game
starts uh very very soon
um this is the first day of the air
things Masters we are starting off with
winners quarterfinal matches and the
winners of today's matches will go
through to the winners semi-finals
tomorrow but the losers they're not
knocked out because of this double
eliminations the loser is they go down
to the losers bracket to play loser is
round one tomorrow would it be a huge
shock if Magnus Carlson already on day
two is on the losers bracket I think it
would be more surprising to the public
than it would be to me because Alexis
Serana is that talented he's that good
and he's beaten the likes of as Tanya
said do buff Nakamura Carlson in
consecutive rounds in the world Blitz
now different type patrols mean
different games more or less but you
still have those results to your name
that is still a huge accomplishment and
I think Serana can do it I really hope
Magnus Carlson is paying these guys well
I'm on Hamilton and foreign
for Magnus wow even the best need a bit
of help sometimes so we have both the
chess bras together now with the world
number one Magnus Carlsen is there
actually like a chess Bra House yeah
there is that sounds like a lot of fun
what I wouldn't give to you to be there
right now and I think that's in Toronto
Robert you maybe know better yeah they
moved it recently I believe they are in
Toronto now and well it's clear that the
move may have messed with their Tech a
little bit but Magnus smiling all of
them happy and the chess Bros I mean
they're very well known to the community
and hopefully they are toned down some
of the electro music and how the
partying because Magnus needs to focus
today and it is quite early in the day
so maybe the partying hasn't started yet
a big smile on Magnus Carlson's face
playing from Toronto and the big chess
bra house getting ready for his first
game both the chance Bros haven't I left
the room
so that must mean we should be about to
start and now we also have Alexa Serrano
joining us very nice to see him as well
there's such a contrast between the two
players I don't think I've seen Magnus
this happy before the start of the Run
that's true I don't think I've seen him
arrive on time for a round two to begin
with actually a morning round a morning
run and Serana they're looking super
focused yeah
I've heard that surround is playing from
Serbia I'm not sure
um about that but either way he's so
good so quick over the board online even
faster
and uh I think we'll be about to start
any second now
I can't wait I feel like this turns away
I feel like I'm looking at a passport
photo I'm surrounded there right like
someone take a photo get him that visa
and let him get on his way but he wants
this match to start I think the Jitters
start settling in and once you have to
sit and wait once those first moves are
made it's just chest to focus on yeah or
a mug shot
guilty of playing some great chess so
let's say Serana he uh qualified from
the big Swiss and the play-ins that was
played on Friday knocking out some huge
names such as Fabiano caruana and
earning his box here and there are
things monsters to play a quart final
match against Magnus Carlsen
it's long overdue and let's hope the
first moves come on the board very
shortly it is 15 minutes on the clock
for each player three seconds increment
after each move so they will have to
adjust a little bit from being used to
10 seconds increment on the tour can
they how long kind of the thinking
breaks can they allow themselves David
um during these rapid games you don't
want to be going into the tank for too
long early on you have to really limit
yourself to these really short things
you have to trust your instinct a lot
more than you do in classical chess
sometimes for calculation but then the
top players do that very quickly too so
I do feel that whoever gets off to the
quicker start will have an early
advantage in the first games of the day
but uh yeah we'll see it looks like none
of the quarterfinals have yet kicked off
so we will
uh impatiently await I hear a rumors
it's getting very close though he is the
reigning champion in the Champions chest
or both last season and the first season
Magnus Carlsen can he win it a third
time it's not decided until December who
is the Undisputed champion this is only
the very first game the beginning of the
Champions chess tour 2023 and the
beginning of the year thanks monsters
I'm so excited now to see what will be
his miners Crossing will he and he's you
know he's sat there now for almost 15
minutes
do you think he's changed his mind over
those 15 minutes or do you think he's
been his mind has been set on an opening
move
the first game he kind of knows what he
wants to do already but as the March
progresses we've often seen him in
interviews say that he sort of takes the
decision on the Fly between rounds so I
think he has it in mind what he wants to
start with and we've been talking about
how Serana is a dangerous opponent but
guy it's also so hard to bet against
Magnus on any given day as you said the
reigning the defending champion of the
Champions Chester High School world
champion World Blitz Champion War rapper
Champion how to call him an underdog no
Magnus is the heavy favor we all know it
but Serana will have to push that all
aside focus on the objective moves he
has a chance that's all you can ask for
when you're playing Magnus Carls yeah
well I was about to say has Serana moved
in the last five minutes he finally did
it's not a passport picture this is a
live shot of him meanwhile Magnus
Carlson going for the maximum Bachelor
grave approach of snacking off during
the game gets it right and here we go
yay and I am the first one with the
right move you guys yay we have started
this is the Champions Chester in 2023 so
here we go Robert was also correct with
his prediction of the Catalan
off our game Teamwork Makes a dreamer
let's start Good Start what are we
seeing on the board you guys so this is
one of the main lines of the Catalan
opening this is uh played by a bunch of
top players in the world seemingly
everyone has it in their repertoire
right now white tries to occupy some of
the center but black is Rock Solid look
at Black's Pawn structure in the middle
um it's what we call the triangle uh
Pawn set up just controlling lots of
squares black does have one problem
piece in these positions it is that
black Bishop the light Square Bishop on
C8 tends to struggle to get out it's
often a battle of the middle game that
we will about be about to see of whether
black can activate that piece and this
is still very well trodden uh this path
what do you guys think uh who's this
gonna favor star wise well Magnus we saw
him employ the Kaplan so much in the
world championship and ever since then
uh in the match against janaponishi and
it seems to suit him really well I think
the fact that he's chosen such a
Mainline Theory against Serana it shows
a lot of respect for his opponent as
well uh the Catalan you can't fault that
line we see it super trendy at the high
level I think it's it's a very wise
choice by Magnus taking on someone as
strong as Serana and I think Serana has
played this very well we're still in
standard opening fair about this move
Knight bd7 in the last move played
developing the Knight is less common
than simply casting the king so that may
seem like an innocuous move but it begs
the question what is the idea is there
something slightly different a Nuance a
wrinkle that Magnus has to take into
account and I believe David that's why
he's thinking yeah it has forced Magnus
to think for himself for the first time
in this game he could as you mentioned
there Robert just automatically Castle
the white king to safety just say okay
what is your idea and that would be
going back to more typical Waters but is
there a difference
uh now Magnus Carlsen adapting to this
rapid format he spent a long time over a
minute on a very standard position I'm
predicting that he will cast it as king
I just don't see what else for white
simply but uh Magnus will he come up
with a more creative approach well 97 as
you mentioned isn't the most popular
move in fact black does go shot Castle
instead which is perhaps what Magnus was
expecting and to just give you some
perspective you've got over 450 games in
shot castle and just about 100 games
with this move that Serana has chosen
and blitzed out shows good preparation
from Alex's side now once again Magnus
could decide to go shark Castle which is
the most popular move in this position
about 158 games here or play the move
Bishop F4 as I can see in my database
with only two games Magnus is definitely
in a new position right now so the these
seem to be the two most logical moves
either castling the most standard
approach or Bishop to F4 I would be
shocked if Magnus didn't Castle I guess
the idea behind uh this one Tanya is to
free up the square on D2 for the White
Knight but there we go we see on the
live board he has played it getting
ready to park the Knight on D2 which is
actually its dream square and uh after
black castles I'm I would be shocked
again if Magnus doesn't go for that but
uh now Knight bd2 would support a pawn
push and uh looks like on my board we've
seen something really creative from
Magnus it hasn't popped up just yet but
uh this would be what I would go for if
I were white Let's uh go back to the
players and what has Magnus got up his
sleeve well you said creative so I'm
guessing it's Harry the H Pawn yeah and
that must be it and it comes from the
school of Daniel do Bob dubov was one of
the trainers from Magnus Carlson during
his world championship matches and dubov
is kind of the king of the Catalan he
loves this opening he plays it with
great effect so they have H2 to H4
throwing that pawn up the board it
doesn't have an immediate threat but it
just can be a bit scary for black to
deal with I see it yeah there you go uh
Roberts he's definitely been hanging out
with Daniel dubov a bit too much
the white king now has the question to
answer long term does it Castle short
does it Castle on the king side now that
you've started pushing pawns on that
flank or do you just stay in the center
keep your opponent guessing um that's
something that Kai has mentioned in the
past especially last season on the tour
it's a definite Trend at the top level
to keep your opponents guessing to kind
of play a bit risky and leave your king
in the center but uh yeah the idea is
clear you want to start stepping forward
even further you're staying very
flexible with white and if Serana isn't
careful maybe a king size attack a bit
later on and you definitely have to
watch out for that this is ambitious
play by Magnus and we see Serana go for
the option of B6 still keeping
flexibility in the center at some point
I am expecting a pontree to try and open
up some files your opponent goes for the
flank attack you try to open on the
center try that on Castle King put
pressure on that and as the pieces
develop I think the way for black hair
David is often to just take out the the
bishop on CA get it to B7 trade the pawn
on C4 pick that pawn up put your knight
on D5 and try to create play in the
center as long as white skin is not
castled yeah so this uh looks like it's
a very logical plan instead Serana has
developed his bishop and uh okay we're
waiting for Magnus to move now what do
we think is he gonna Castle is he gonna
decide is he gonna go left right King
side Queen side is he just going to
leave it even longer and maybe Advance
his Pawn in the center uh so many
questions
it does look very kind of surprising to
me that Magnus has gone for something
this provocative it feels like just cast
your king you know play all the simple
moves first it's the first game of the
day it's a morning round but uh what do
you think of this Robert something I
like to point out is that Knight on D7
right from the queen it's dominated by
The Pawn on D4 so when there's a pawn
three squares away from a knight the
Knight is in some trouble so I do like
the Contours of the position for white
because that black Knight's a bit
passive so playing the E4 it's a very
common it's a topical idea but you offer
some trades and that's usually good for
the side with less space than Knight 97
the Knight F6 fighting for the same
squares called Superfluous Knights
thanks to Jeremy Silman so I do think
we'll see a series of trades in the 997
will become a happier piece yeah finally
the knights can start to breathe and it
would have a nice Square it could attack
the White Queen for example but okay
what is Magnus Carlson done he didn't
automatically recapture let's go back to
the game because I was certainly
expecting an automatic take on this uh
E4 square but instead of capturing the
spawn Magna says no I'm going for the
attack he brings this Knight forward of
course this Pawn will disappear long
term it's now attacked four times the
white Bishop is open towards it but uh
he's also hinting at a potential attack
on this square look how the Queen's
Vision long uh long x-ray vision there
is potentially going to hit the H7 pawn
and Serana doesn't even blink he's
playing so quickly against this really
creative idea he plays C5 again if your
opponent attacks one side
fight back in the center the bar is
really liking it for Magnus yeah the
evaluation bar we should mention on the
side there on the left of the board up
on white side yeah surprising to me
especially considering Saran is playing
so quickly feels like he's in his home
preparation somehow but
um we've got to trust the engine from
time to time and speed with which the
players are blitzing out their moves it
seems as if they know what they're doing
but this is a brand new position it's
never happened before so they are
playing over the board this move by
Magnus going Knight to G5 attacking on
e4 and now he blocks off the center
blocks off that bishop and B7 this Pawn
Advance is a very typical way of getting
back to the position after black has
made the move C5 you want to keep it
blocked and you want to keep pressure on
e4 I like this approach of not allowing
black to capture on D4 and opening up
the center yeah he's opening it in a way
that could potentially be favorable for
white he's saying okay we can open it up
but on my terms and what do we think is
this involving a second Pawn sacrifice
temporarily maybe we have to jump in and
show some lines here Robert I think so
because it looks like after D5 black has
that square under control you can start
taking that pawn on D5 and that has just
happened e65 was played white has to
take back with the pawn and if we get
some trades on that square white will
then castle queenside at long last and
black will be two pawns but white has
the initiative the momentum is the favor
there's a pin down the default the E4
Pawn will be hanging maybe there's some
better moves along the way I mean
castling King was now strong just
bringing the Rook to D1 but either way
we see how quickly White's Pieces come
into the flow of the position yeah just
to go one or two moves further if the
black Bishop drops back we can for
example take this Pawn simply with our
Bishop and look at this already
devastating threats on the board this is
a huge threat of Checkmate the black
king not entirely safe and actually I
don't really see how to prevent this and
this could be really dangerous already
and this is the current position of
course we're waiting to see if Serana
does take this Pawn there is a threat
however of stepping forward one square
to trap the black Bishop so uh already
huge questions for Serana to answer wow
what a star you guys to the 2023 season
Magnus Carlsen maybe about to uh Castle
opposite sides yeah that's very likely
yeah it's going to bring some action now
we want you guys at home to join in the
conversation to join us here in the
studio and you can do so either uh
participating in the twitch chat or by
tweeting us using the hashtag chess
Champs we want to hear your questions
your comments we want to know who you're
rooting for and we want to see your
selfies as well so share them using the
hashtag chess Champs and actually during
this tournament the air things monsters
every day we're gonna give out an air
things device too one of you sharing a
selfie on Twitter using the hashtag
chess champ so go ahead and show us your
face we want to see it
yeah and talking of faces we see Magnus
in deep concentration right now on the
camera he I think is trying to hide his
excitement here Magnus for sure he's got
in a brand new idea you mentioned
earlier Tanya we've never seen this
position before and uh he's used it and
really kind of uh it's of course an
important game but uh Serrano wouldn't
have expected this he wouldn't have been
expecting Magnus to go straight for his
throat uh suppressing stuff surprising
stuff that I think Magnus is super happy
with the way the opening has turned out
and we've been talking about this white
Pawn on D5 and how black can capture it
it might be the only way forward uh
David this threat that you pointed out
of D6 and look at the Serana chooses
another part of locating a square for
the bishop
with the move Knight to H5 and the bar
hits it yeah yeah the bar hates this
move we have to try and figure out why
of course it's not just because Knights
on the rim are dim that could be one
explanation of course but it must be
something concrete something specific to
this position that makes the engine hate
this position I hate this last decision
so much by Serana I'm trying to figure
it out it feels like white has a bunch
of ways to create a double attack but no
Magnus just takes the time out and drops
this bishop back what do we think of
this movie the problem was it was a one
move threat the Knight attacked the
bishop on F4 the bishop simply slides
away from the attack and this Pawn E4 is
going to be won by white if you try to
push your Pawn up from F7 to F5 to give
it the opponent's best friend another
Pawn then then the E6 square is
vulnerable the Knight can simply hop in
there that wins some material for white
it's a fork that wins a rook for just
the night there so white would have the
edge I feel like Knight H5 it kicked the
bishop back the question is then what I
don't know the answer to that question
yeah I don't think Serana knows the
answer to that question either normally
if you create a threat your opponent
answers it then you should be able to
quickly show the rest of your plan but
uh yeah as Robert says this looks like a
bit of a one mover and suddenly white
will capture this Pawn with any piece
you can take it in four different ways
next move and again the threats persist
this king is about to come under a huge
attack
looking good for white I've got to say
and sometimes we disagree with the
engine the evaluation bar sometimes it's
hard to understand why the computer says
certain things here it's quite logical I
feel black Pieces Just Don't Look ready
for the action in the center most of
them are passive and the only piece
that's stepped away and out of the first
two ranks is this horrible Knight on H5
which will be forced to retreat at some
point to a more defensive square but has
it gone all wrong for Serana here in the
opening or do you think this is part of
his plan I think it's gone completely
wrong for him because Magnus has control
over the position sometimes you have an
advantage but there's only one series of
moves that leads to that edge here all
of White's pieces are on great squares
black is one piece activated like David
said but it's on the rim not doing much
now the bishop slid away so I believe
with only one Pawn to his name and that
pawn is likely to fall soon this is not
a good position for Lexi serrana
yeah and I think he's starting to
realize the seriousness of uh his issues
here his problems uh he's been tanking
for a while and wow Robert he goes for
the move move you suggested logical but
it does come at a cost and Magnus jumps
in instantly he doesn't uh hesitate to
drop his Knight on that beautiful E6
square that is a fork you gotta move the
Queen the queen would be more valuable
of the two pieces she runs away but uh
here Magnus again spoiled for choice
that white knight Is So Glorious so
beautiful do you even trade it for a
rook yes you were material but maybe you
want to keep it on that square we call
it an octopus Knight with its tentacles
all over the board that white knight is
a real thorn in Black side and I
wouldn't be shocked if Magnus just
ignores it just castles Queen side and
says okay the attack continues
and Jack always has to watch out for a
G4 break we see the spawn chain in the
center this E4 Pawn being guarded by
this F5 pawn and you want to break that
and has he gone it does it he does it
instantly uh but he doesn't care about
the king safety he says I'm coming for
yorking instead G4 and I see the eval
bar loves it on the board this has
exploded already hitting that night
hitting that pawn if you capture on G4
all white ones is to take on e4 and hit
that pawn on 87 and it's really all
about the black king that Knight on E6
is way worth more than an exchange yeah
this Knight is uh one of the most
beautiful pieces I've seen in a while
and uh serrana he's facing an attack
he's about to drop uh drop some material
it just looks right I mean I want to say
hopeless but not quite yet it does look
really difficult for him though the only
alternative to that is dropping back the
night but that's an admission of defeat
you've kind of wasted a bunch of Tempe
with that night move and there'll be
ideas of hitting the black queen with
the bishop there'll be ideas of just
taking a pawn opening up a line for the
white Rook later in the game and uh just
the problems they're adding up they're
building and no salvation here it's one
of those moments I think you have to
take the pawn and pray yeah like I'm
just going to take what's being offered
to me and hope I can survive it it's not
looking good as we're noting E4 Pawn
will drop you can at any moment take
this Rook on f8 but you don't need to do
that but if we do a quick material count
that's the thing is currently white
would be down two pawns you're likely to
win one back right away and even if you
do eventually take that Rook on a fade
it will be a minor piece and one Pawn
for a rook that is four points for five
that's not an insurmountable lead at
least in terms of material so there are
chances for Serana he will need to play
more quickly and he'll need to trust
himself a little bit but thus far he has
gotten himself in huge trouble yeah huge
trouble and as Robert says you just got
to limit the damage we've all found
ourselves in these situations where we
get kind of attacked in the opening it
all goes wrong we just have to find ways
to survive look for any defensive
resources that you can find and so right
he tends to be quite good at that he's
quite tenacious as a Defender I found uh
when studying his games so uh he'll just
be looking for ways as Robert mentions
as well to part with material in order
to survive the longer you survive the
more confidence you build up and maybe
the more frustrated Magnus will become
but uh now down a couple of minutes on
the clock as well and with that only
three second increment that we see in
this uh new season of the tour it's
gonna be a real struggle for him all the
pieces still on the board only a few
points have disappeared so still very
tense still some chances but he needs to
speed up Magnus looks anything but
frustrated right now he is definitely
enjoying this position a lot he's got
everything it's like a dream Cat Land
for him the opponent has got about six
minutes Serana down to six minutes on
the clock a really difficult position to
defend already uh this has gone all
wrong for uh for Alexi it's not looking
good on the bar or on the clock for
Alexa Serana in the first of four games
in the other matches we could see the
evaluation bars roughly to the middle so
more 10 start maybe in the other
matchups yeah it does look like maybe
the bar is slightly in uh nakamura's
favor that was a really fascinating game
we'll keep you guys updated if the
results come in there and uh we'll
mention some highlights a bit later but
yeah this one looking difficult what's
your philosophy Robert Tanya when you
were really struggling when you know
your opponents almost got it in the bag
but you have to survive you have to
fight back
sure I will take this one I think that
Serana is a speed demon he is really
resourceful when he even is down to his
final seconds he has great experience in
rapping and Blitz time patrols so at
some point he's just take what's offered
to him and run with it he did just take
this Pawn on G4 he is up two pawns at
the moment it's not like there's an
immediate Checkmate or even an immediate
devastating threat so his position is
worse he acknowledges that you could see
it on his face but it's not that
terrible so as long as he can show up
and prevent the immediate threats he
does have a chance in this game and we
see Magnus just take this Pawn on e4
with the bishop creating a threat
against the HM Pawn but the evaluation
bar is taking a little bit of a dip a
knight can come out to F6 there is
activity for blacks pieces and that's
the best news of all yeah and uh at
least his next couple of moves are very
natural he did bring a knight to F6 as a
bit of a defensive Rock there blacks
Knights Superfluous perhaps but they do
control and defend cover some really
important squares Magnus eventually
after resisting the Temptation for a few
moves he has gone to grab the materials
so white has won that Rook for his
Knight he's currently one point up if we
do a count but uh yeah it's more about
the peace activity white has nice
centralization black needs to just uh
lock things down and I like this last
move by Serana planting the black Bishop
on D6 the dark Square Bishop blockading
white Central Pawn you cannot allow that
one to advance it would be too strong it
would win the game and uh he seems to
have done a good job of at least
covering things for now holding things
together
do we think Magnus has a breakthrough
now or is he just going to improve his
pieces as we see in front of us I love
that approach he's already up materially
he just brings the last piece into the
game bring all your toys most of the
nursery as they say and Rook to E1
centralizing it David as you were
talking about the approach in such
difficult positions I think your mindset
just has to be to survive another move
you just have to make sure that you're
not losing on the spot and keep pushing
your opponent to find ways because the
hardest thing in chess is to win a
winning position we've seen even Magnus
sometimes not being able to do it uh so
that is what Serana is trying to do he's
trying to keep himself in the game but
it's going to be hard this one I like I
like that why does material up and it
looks like white has all the
compensation as well why is it hard to
win a winning position but easy to lose
a losing one chess isn't fair
I was yelled at by Henry Carlson Magnus
carlsen's father once in a polite way
because I asked him something about
Magnus he only needs to draw and Henrik
said it is very difficult to guess
and of course it is and it must be even
harder to as you say win a winning
position yeah all of these guys they're
super strong they're here for a reason
they're all beasts and they all defend
extremely well I think that's what sets
the modern generation apart from past
years uh thanks to engines we've all
learned that there are resources in
positions and especially the young
players they're so so resourceful and
Serana still fighting back still
struggling perhaps objectively but at
least he started to advance pawns
towards towards the white king I do want
to mention just a couple of moves ago
the experience of these two especially
in speed chess has show has Shone
through by the fact they both put their
kings towards the corner black took a
time out to shuffle his King into the
corner Magnus even though he's the one
attack talking with white took a time
out put his King on a safer square and
that's just because later you don't want
to have to calculate checks attacks and
direct threats but uh talking of direct
threats that Rook on E6 now the white
Rook has landed on a square that the
White Knight used to occupy but still an
outpost still defended by White's past
Pawn in the center and of course by his
bishop and even if black trades off that
Rook it will just be replaced by an
equally powerful Pawn Yeah minus has so
many Intruders in the black Camp right
now yeah and uh those intruders are only
going to start eroding the black
position further
um this last move is a bit of a sad one
but I love it though I mean from the
defensive perspective you can't trade
pieces just gonna lose any end game you
are down material so Rook d8 threatens
in a way I put it in air quotes because
it's not a big threat but Bishop's
sliding back to its home Square hitting
the Rook on E6 and the bishop 105 behind
it so all of a sudden you know he's
putting up sturdy defense he's much
worse perhaps objectively lost but he at
least is keeping all of his pieces
connected with one another and that
doesn't allow a Magnus to knock out blow
yep actually everything's defending each
other right now these Knights are kind
of clinging onto each other for dear
life uh this bishop the blockader of
that powerful white Pawn uh It is Well
defended for now well fortified I do
wonder if Magnus can start upping the
pressure I'm not sure whether you have
time to bring your Rook uh kind of
pocket doubled Rooks there instead
Magnus centralizes his Knight wow nice
move and adding even more pressure onto
those two uh kind of most important
Defenders exchanging pieces as well as
Robert mentioned helping uh when you're
ahead on material
yeah I love this move 94. uh that Knight
on F6 with the spin on The d8 Rook you
just want to get rid of that and your
task becomes that much easier you're
also hitting that Bishop on D6 uh that's
how you're fighting against the threat
of a bishop to C8 as you were mentioning
uh Robert and I think everything that
Magnus has done so far seems like
Flawless play yeah
just seems really relaxed I've never
seen Magnus like this in the mornings
normally he takes a while to warm up but
he just looks really relaxed and uh
using this opening idea he's never let
Serana kind of get a foot into this game
I was talking about getting off to a
fast start earlier Serana shaking his
head he's normally ice cold emotionless
and uh Fearless but Serana shaking his
head there he has played Bishop to F4
trying to trade off these Pieces perhaps
these Bishops will that help him this
Pawn has also been freed up to start
advancing in the near future not right
now perhaps but some calculation to be
done Magnus
Bishop F4 you can also start thinking
about doing all kinds of trades on F6
and really taking Black's defenses away
the G4 Pawn will fall the 87 Pawn will
be not defended uh I'm expecting a bunch
of Trades of these defensive resources
that Serana has with these two knights
and meanwhile we do see the bar has
swung in nakamura's favor against kakash
nothing big has happened there yeah some
big developments potentially in that
game and of course we've seen the bar
all up in White's favor in this game too
for a long time now and Tanya predicted
the future yet again and a capture of
Black's Defender that Knight on F6
and it is replaced but that night the
second night will also disappear any
second now
the two biggest favorites could be about
to get a perfect start to the other
things monsters Magnus Carlsen and
Hikaru Nakamura the bar is also going
out for another
small favorite we must call him that
Oliver again Sergeant aragaisy in the
first game yeah there is a definitely
the favorite at least on paper he's high
rated in classical chess Arjun had a
terrible event in Vikings day he didn't
win a single game he lost a number of
them but we know what he's capable of so
ordinary guys he finds his form he can
definitely combat other as a fruga yeah
and also we haven't seen others are that
much in action where is this practice
coming from right now and these kind of
formats just demand you to be on the go
from the very start of course alireza
had a very comfortable going in with the
Swiss and the playoffs but uh Arjun
we've seen him on the tour before and
what's interesting is that I don't
remember these two teenagers playing
against each other so this thing could
be the first time this matchup is
happening and alireza was one of the
first in this generation to sort of
break away use world number two and I
mean far ahead of everyone but he sort
of inspired this younger generation uh
to come forward and this change of God
this movement that we're talking about
alireza was right in the front of it and
especially with your fellow Indians
Tanya with gukash with arjunar guys with
Prague nananda there's so many of them
yeah and and to think that they're all
the same age it's kind of hard to
imagine but at some point you felt like
alireza broke away and went a little
further and sort of just giving these
other youngsters this inspiration that
they can do it as well and now to see
these two fight against each other I
think it's going to be a big match it
doesn't matter who's stronger on paper
uh arches gonna give a big fight he's
also super good in these speeches faster
formats yeah
so I just love the fact that farouja in
the play ends on Friday he was playing
from his kitchen
I'm curious to follow him a bit later I
wonder if he's uh following the same
recipe for success but uh meanwhile
Magnus planting that White Queen in the
center Black's Bishop is plugging all
the holes uh that dark Square Bishop now
for black but it could be removed at any
moment first Magnus gobbles up a pawn
he's getting ready to throw the white F
Pawn forward to destabilize that black
Bishop in the center and
this one looks uh like uh we're coasting
now towards victory for Magnus Carlson
and the Queen the White Queen was over
and near the king now it's going near
the enemy King it just took a pawn it's
gonna slide up on the diagonal and go
after the black king on h8 Queen H5
threatened Checkmate H7 also allows The
Rook to land on E8 in many positions it
protects that square so this is a big
problem for serrana I think he is
completely hopelessly lost I don't say
that very often as a commentator but
this position it's he's getting
obliterated in this one yeah and just to
highlight the idea that Robert mentioned
that for example if Bishop takes Pawn is
played white can even give up his Rook
for that strong Bishop in the center and
now create that threat those dual
threats actually uh firstly Checkmate on
the H7 square but now that this black
Rook has been lured away from the E8
Square secondary threat is just as
devastating and this could spell game
over at this point it's hard to offer
any advice for Serana he might as well
play a move such as this one and ask
Magnus to prove uh the win to show the
win because it's inevitable at this
point you just need to find the most
testing way for your opponent is looking
hopeless also down under two minutes for
Serana what does he play he pushes a
pawn forward this doesn't change
anything however he's looking for
counter play he's pushing pawns towards
towards the white king but he's so far
away he needs three or four moves to
create a single threat and Magnus will
land a punch before that
and now that he's allowed to deep on to
stay alive David that Bond can actually
go forward to D6 and also threaten The
Rook coming on to the seventh rank so
let's say you start with the move Queen
H5 it's on the board you're threatening
a meeting one and Serana has to defend
that with the queen losing control of
the D6 Square after which let's say
queen goes to G7 defending the mate on
87 and a move like D6 would be
absolutely devastating coming in with
the Rook on the seventh Rank and this is
Checkmate incoming uh Serrano's down to
a minute and a half and the clock is not
even his biggest problem yeah we saw it
in the camera a minute ago he was just
rubbing his eyes he's like what happened
and this has just been a powerful
display by Magnuson we can't fault
Serrano at all he's uh just not really
been given a chance in this game it's
sometimes happens against the top guys
in the world yeah he was in unfamiliar
position and Magnus was on the attack
surrounder felt uncomfortable he brought
his Knight to the rim and it never quite
got back in the game except when it was
traded off the board in a winning
position for Magus Carlson so this is
dominance this is the world number one
player for oh over the last decade he's
showing his force in game one and he's
about to lead one nil I think
resignation and coming yep I think we
have the result Magnus did get his Rook
to the seventh Rank and Serana has
resigned wow 32 moves and it's over at
Magnus Carlson he takes the first punch
the first point in the quarterfinal
match against Alexa Serana
the Russian will have to make a comeback
he will have the white pieces in game
two the other matches they are still
playing the first games and we're gonna
jump into the first game between Hikaru
Nakamura the online Beast against 16
year old gukesh the oldest against the
youngest in the air things monster is
actually and the bar is loving it for
Hikaru of Nakamura are you loving it
Robert I am indeed and the reason why is
if you do a quick material count uh
White is down one Pawn but essentially
being down two pawns on the queen side
where there are two unopposed passers
and there we go A5 pushes one of them
and then white is up one Pawn over there
on the king side but white is not
creating a pass Pawn because Black's
King is in the way so I believe the
white forces will be distracted we'll
have to run on over to stop the pawns
and then black can then scoop up the
remaining Pawns of whites so I think
this is actually a straightforward
victory for Nakamura yeah Knights are
famously bad as well against these Rooks
Pro ones against the a h pawns and white
knight is going to be completely
paralyzed stopping that runner on the a
file he does go cash centralize his
Knight heading towards the queen side
but yeah this one it feels like it
should be a matter of time the one uh
kind of potential hurdle here the one
potential banana skin for Nakamura is
that all the pawns disappear you can't
allow the White Knight to trade off all
the pawns because a knight on its own
for black would not be enough to deliver
Checkmate thankfully he has four of them
left to those pawns and I don't think
ukesh should be able to trade them all
off
what's gone wrong for the young Indian
in this game
Nakamura
you're facing one of the best endgame
players of all time you're pulling down
it was very tense for a long time
earlier but it feels like uh go cash
kind of cracked at a very uh crucial
moment in Nakamura since then hasn't put
a foot wrong yet should still be able to
guide this one towards Victory his King
has been pushed back however fair play
to kokesh he's at least asking questions
he's saying can you win the same game
without your king Nakamura shaking his
head I must say I haven't seen him play
from this location before it's uh
different from his usual uh streaming
place I guess but uh okay okay shaking
his head a little bit yeah and the bar
for the first time at least slightly
showing some white uh kukash has stopped
those black porns in their track for now
is there a way to break this what do we
think
well the good news is that one night on
B5 takes care of both of the black pawns
at least for the moment and you see the
Black Knight go back towards the White
ponds you're just trying to keep white
uh excuse me black stuck in place on the
queen side and then black is trying to
go after the Pawns of the king side but
the white king can slide over and save
that pawn and if the pawns get traded
like you're mentioning David that gives
white chances what you need to do is
eliminate all four blacks pawns and even
if that costs you your knight you will
be able to make a draw a lone King and
Knight cannot deliver a Checkmate so all
of a sudden Hikaru he's looking a bit
frazzled and maybe he believes that
gokish has a chance yeah and under one
minute now for Hikaru and wow what a
move giving up his night offering that
night as bait and he's counted very well
here he's uh realized it is a race let's
go in and show this night sacrifice
again uh because uh Nakamura now giving
up his night if it's captured it's a
race between this pawn two squares away
from promotion and this night
unfortunately the Knight cannot get back
in time to stop this Pawn from becoming
a queen we mentioned that night
especially bad against these Rook porns
and it's going to be a new Queen on the
A1 square and therefore if the Knight
cannot be captured it must be driven
away and if White Knight if the white
knight runs for example to retreat the
black pawns can start rolling uh once
more what a move Tanya what an idea at
97 I absolutely love it as you mentioned
the knights are the worst Defenders
against the flank pawns and Knight C7
just on pre-grip giving up a whole piece
but the a pawn is super fast and the
main idea of this move by Hikaru is of
course to try to push the beep on to
assist the a pawn uh to queening and he
sort of found the fastest way to Victory
and I'm just thinking very often the
players say that you know what hikaru's
Expressions can be so deceptive and that
little head shake that we just saw by
him and then he plays this fabulous
Knight C7 calculating it to Victory I
think it's one of those moments don't go
by what you see with Hikaru yeah he's
full of those expressions which throw us
off but also throw his opponents off and
uh yeah his a pawn now is only two
squares away that white knight and that
black Acorn basically cancel each other
out and finally those heads uh the Bops
I don't know what to call them Hikaru
knows he's winning yeah and uh yeah this
one's a matter of time and we have
another huge result you guys we were
looking at alireza Rosa origin ergasi
saying that it was looking quite good
for all the rest of Russia something has
happened here Arjun Eric icy takes the
first point wow and what a way to win I
just looked over at that game if you
want it with the queen sacrifice Robert
yeah it was a beautiful queen sacrifice
at the end so he was able to take game
one a gorgeous play from our generic icy
and his compatriot his friend Gucci he's
struggling now against Nakamura down a
pawn in this end game and I think looks
word deceiving uh Hikaru Nakamura
shaking his head but when all of a
sudden done this one the b and a pawns
they're too far Advanced the Knight on
A6 is shepherding them towards the other
side and I believe that black will
simply get a queen and if that Queen is
stopped then that requires the white
king to dark all the way over over to
the queen side and the black king will
scoop up the remaining white Pawn so
this is an easy finish for a car
Nakamura at this point yeah and kokesh
now down to his final couple of seconds
he needs to move oh he made that move I
think with two seconds left he's running
with the white king towards that side
but there we go I think we have the
result confirmed no way to stop those
pawns from running now the pawns will
become a queen and kakesh gives up
Karu takes the win it's over another win
for a big favorite Hikaru Nakamura with
the black piece that takes the win
against
will have the black pieces in the next
game and he has to make a comeback at
some point remember it is best out of
four rapid games this one is still going
on Ralph mamado against Wesley so this
is game one and the bar is as much in
the middle as it possibly can be I think
it says gonna be a draw they do say that
all Rook end games are drawn and uh this
isn't an exception and here white is a
pawn up but that pawn won't last too
long black won't necessarily actually go
and take that pawn that very far
Advanced White Pawn because it's under
control it's under lock and key the
black king keeps the watchful eye over
it but the black Rook is going to go and
restore material balance by taking
another Pawn look at this F7 Now by
Wesley so he's trying to hint that he'll
make a new Queen but uh he's not quite
quick enough it is becoming a race any
chance here for either side to go wrong
wow that white F1 blink and you miss it
it's disappeared and uh how is Wesley
gonna hold the draw here suddenly he's
the one to pulling down that was quite a
question really quick but lucky for
Wesley here that the king is attacking
the H5 pawn and The Rook from f8 cuts
off the black king will come to defend
its g-pawn which is advancing and this
is going to end in a draw it's trickier
than you would expect and that's why he
brought the king back if he took that
pawn on H5 what's happening might have
been trouble it seems suddenly he's
winning oh no it's not the depth issue
sometimes you know it freaks out it goes
somewhere but the king steps back to F4
Wesley understands as long as he picks
up the G2 Pawn the game is immediately a
draw because a king in H Pawn that lone
Position will be a theoretical draw
there's no way for black to dislodge the
white king from the corner so that is
where Wesley is aiming we're getting
just that yeah yeah this game will end
in stalemate but I can confirm for one
move Madoff was winning there really he
actually played the right idea but in
the wrong order he could have played the
same idea but stopping the white king
from coming back to blockade this pawn
and uh yeah and games are so tricky I
wrote it off I said it was going to be a
draw it was a draw but there were always
tricks in the position Wesley surviving
there wow a bit of luck on his side
three matches ended up with winner but
in this one a draw in the first game
Wesley so walks away now five minutes
and we will start the second set of
games only five minutes but before that
we have to take a look at some of the
action that happened in the very first
round of the air things monsters on the
2023 Champions chess tour season this is
today's weather learning points
base learning point is about bringing
all of your pieces to the party
especially when you're trying to attack
this is a position from the game alireza
faroogia as white against Arjun eregasti
as black and we mentioned a cool Queen
sacrifice did happen that was all
because Eric icy brought all of his
pieces towards that white king and they
harmonized so well suddenly The Black
Queen jumped out threatening a nasty
Checkmate the white king trapped in the
corner here a rook had to swing over and
defend and Regice he won a pawn with
this queen for Asia reluctant to go
towards the end game and now bringing
another piece into the attack the Black
Knight jumping in hitting the White
Queen if Queen takes Queen this is a
nasty smothered mate the white king
trapped in the corner here of course the
White Queen couldn't do this it moved
away but now another queen Sacrifice by
uh Eric icy now trying to trick the
White Queen into capturing and this
smothered mate idea persists he won a
very nice game it only lasted a few
moves longer than this but if you
combine all your pieces bring them all
in good things will happen
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
a twitch break for anyone who is
non-subscribers for everyone else we're
now going to dig deeper into the first
round of the Champions chess store 2023
foreign
[Music]
new time control so much stronger yeah I
mean I was completely gobsmacked you
know so much action so much drama and I
can actually say a lot of it was to do
with clock management to time and uh for
instance alireza farouza against Arjun
erag I see that was so cagey so tense
but uh farooza just let his clock run
down and then what you saw at the end he
just panicked he went hard and it
backfired on him and someone else who
pushed too hard was a good cash he went
really really aggressively against
Hikaru Nakamura in the beginning but
that went completely wrong because
Hikaru just calmly defended everything
picked up a pawn and won a name game did
we see the players take a little bit of
risks here in the first game definitely
especially from The Underdogs I would
say I mean they really like tried to
push the boundaries they tried to make
the uh the favorites a little bit
unsettled and to burn and time on the
clock sometimes it was a good strategy
sometimes it didn't work as we saw yeah
and Magnus a big favorite if you want
his game Hikaru a big favorite he won
his game but Arjun eragaisy winning
against olly Reza for Russia is that the
one that impressed you the most yeah
absolutely because they really matched
each other I mean that Frugal definitely
will be very frustrated by that game and
he will definitely be going back to the
drawing board
let's take a look at the results you
guys remember it is best out of four
rapid games Magnus Carl's now in the
lead against Alexa Serana so is Hikaru
Nakamura against yukash and the Arjun
eragazi against Oliver's Russia Wesley
so and Ralph Mama though they are tied
and the second games are coming up very
shortly you guys so get ready for some
more action
we have started this is
Chester
2023. what is Magnus Carlson done he
didn't automatically recapture so Runner
doesn't even blink he's playing so
quickly if you're opponent attacks one
side fight back in the center he doesn't
care about the king's safety he says I'm
coming for your King instead
all right that was fun you guys we have
started how do you feel I feel great we
have some really great clashes to start
the day exciting chess their whole
players are holding nothing back yeah I
mean there was exactly nothing about
holding back no quick draws no saving
anything this was action from the get-go
I mean did you see arjun's game we got a
brief look at it what was that that was
destruction on the board magnets from
the start with that H Pawn going forward
delivering a Checkmate on Serrano almost
and everything was busted there all uh
this is the kind of Chess we love and
we're getting all the action that we
were hoping for definitely and we're
gonna follow now from the start game two
between origin era Galaxy now with the
white pieces against Ali Reza farouja
for Russia he has to make a comeback
yeah at some point today because he did
lose the first game and can you imagine
this self-confidence the Arjun must have
after winning not only the game but in
the fashion he did it yeah not just
winning a really stylish Victory but
also winning with the black pieces in a
Four game match having a win and having
more whites in the remaining games
that's a huge advantage and uh Eric I
see he plays all sorts of openings now
what's going to be interesting for me is
whether he goes again all out attacking
approach which served him so well in the
first game what does he take a Karma
approach I don't think that latter one
will help actually too much against far
Asia because things will get messy at
some point anyway you have to fight fire
with fire but uh that's uh it's gonna be
fascinating his first game was just
incredible both teenagers both 19 years
old do they also have a similar style or
are they very very different kind of
chess players right I think they're
quite different I think that Ali Reza
much prefers an energetic play he
doesn't like sitting in passive
structures whereas for origin aragosi he
doesn't mind maneuvering around the
board he's actually quite mature for his
very young age okay okay so what kind of
game should we then expect
I think Arjun is very combative as well
he does not he's not afraid of taking
decisions that blow up the position it
really depends on what the position
really demands I've seen him play at the
Tata steel chest in India the rapid and
Blitz he's an absolute monster and she
in speeches we've seen him in the
Champions chess store he really thrives
in these formats and alireza loves fire
on the board arjun's ready for it yeah
you will have the white pieces in this
one in the lead Arjun Eric garci uh is
he one of those players who plays
Everything Under the Sun or or does he
have some favorite kind of openings well
when he first burst onto the scene I
felt that he was really kind of an
expert in certain structures certain
types of positions but lately I was
looking at Tata steel Vikings he was
playing everything and not once would he
hold back he had a difficult tournament
there I think losing four or five games
but still every game he'd come back and
go for his opponents and that type of
strategy is gonna really serve him well
in the long term and uh of course he had
a breakout year last year and that was
due to his Universal Style just the fact
he could play anything and had the
confidence to back it up and uh yeah I'm
fascinated to see the first few moves
should we do predictions again yeah yeah
it was served you well last time I'll
keep my D4
am I allowed to copy Kyle because she
was correct the first time I want to
join you this time again
44 yeah or the D14 yeah yeah I'll go
with Knight F3 okay I'll go
I still remember the good ones G3
and uh okay we have uh farouza on our
picture it looks like is that his
kitchen again
uh maybe a change of scenery for alireza
ah maybe the one thing that hasn't
changed is
true and then just goes on to blow up
the board yes you might be going to bed
soon it's very late in India so it's
nearing bedtime for him but you are
correct through all the events we've
seen him play he won the junior speeches
Championship beating nihal sarin in an
epic final it looked like he didn't even
break a sweat wow wow
then he also made it all the way to uh
the final and the Julius bear generation
Cup last season Arjun aragaisy he did
lose two Magnus Carlsen but he played a
fantastic tournament to make it all the
way to the final in that one
did he really make his big breakthrough
last year Our Generation it felt like
that it felt like everything he touched
turned to gold in 2022 he won a bunch of
tournaments on the online scene he was
steamrolling through some kind of
world-class players and and of course
2023 didn't start off that well for him
but we know he's on a hot streak he's
over 2700 now in classical he's there to
stay and we'll be talking about him both
of these players hopefully for years to
come I really hope for Russia as well
comes back to over the board chess a bit
more in future
um it's been a bit maybe a bit more
mysterious what he's been up to over the
last few months but Eric I see he's been
playing tournament after tournament
after tournament uh barely taking a
pause for breath and that's helped him
improve that's the trick to success so I
went to Total steel to interview a few
players and many of them would mention
Ali reservous as one of the favorites in
the Champions chest for 2023 and they
would also mention something about
fashion that he's gotten into fashion
lately what is that rumor I think that's
uh the other memes right online people
just say that all the time in the chat
uh he might be into fashion but it's
clear that he's still into the chess and
we do have liftoff so the game is
underway here we go game two you guys
between all the rights of food shop and
Arjun all right I see um he might be
into fashion but you guys should get
into panditri I mean
1d4 on the board I love it nailed it
again and uh it's a London system
are we allowed to boo openings here in
the studio it's not because it's a
boring opening I just think that it
creates a situation that is a slower
build up you know it's not going to be a
game oh maybe they'll show differently
but it's usually kind of a calmer start
to these positions yeah I think we're
only allowed to boo the London system
the French and maybe the Berlin
anything else is off limits those three
fair game but uh yeah it has made a
version pause for thoughts I'm very
surprised I must confess because Eric
icy has been doubling in the London
system quite a lot over the last year or
so he's also been playing the job of
London uh many times he used it against
Magnus for example in the world rapid
Championship so uh this surely shouldn't
have come as a surprise if ferrugia was
doing his preparation but maybe he was
just thinking new match situation I'm
down a point I want to play for a win I
can't just choose a solid option I can't
just play for a draw in this one so
farouza fianchetto is his uh his light
squared Bishop over there on the queen
side I was about to say could we be
going towards a queen's Indian type of
setup but D6 there pushing upon just
blocking the London Bishop the white
Dart squared Bishop there very sensible
he's getting ready to bring more pieces
out and
start keeping Eric I see guessing here
it's very much out of the Realms of
theory here it's just about who
understands the plans the setups better
in the uh ensuing middle game I also
like how flexible both players have kept
their structures black and also fear and
chat or the other Bishop I was just
about to say from the king's side G6 and
the bishop lands on this long diagonal
white not committing the seat Bond so
here Arjun is deciding whether he wants
to put it to C3 or to C4 for a more
aggressive approach in the center
first we might see Eric icy just get his
King to safety and get the white king
Castle's London system players they
follow a tried and tested method here a
system in the opening they just want to
put the white Bishop out maybe you only
need to get the white king castled drop
the dart Square Bishop back and then
start playing chess and then start
playing the game the London system not
everyone's favorite loads of memes out
there for it but hopefully this one will
liven up at some point yep
We are following the second game our
generic icy is in the lead and I've seen
a bunch of your selfies popping up on
the screen as well we do love to see
that you guys joining in on the action
share your selfie on Twitter using the
hashtag chess Champs and every day
during the air things monsters we will
pick a selfie winner of an air things
device it's actually signed by Magnus
Carlsen himself so enter the competition
by sharing your selfie we want to see
where in the world you're watching the
chess from who you're watching it with
is it late at night is it early in the
morning for you wherever you are in the
world share your selfies so if I share a
selfie of who I'm watching with yeah the
three of you yeah do I automatically win
you don't automatically win but you
automatically enter the competition
we'll fix it so that you don't win
we might also be able to hook you up
with an air thanks device I appreciate
that yeah
and we'll talk about that more
throughout the event but air quality we
have found in past seasons in past years
that it has had a direct effect on the
players uh the quality of their play and
we've seen Magnus Carlsen play well when
he's got great air quality Anish giri
really lives so he kind of swears by the
air things device so hopefully whoever
gets it in the end will use it to kind
of benefit their chess I mean so
important for chess players with the
online chess playing from their homes to
have good air quality if CO2 levels are
super high it's gonna be hard to
concentrate for sure and something else
that needs air is someone's position and
you see the last movie that was played
the pawn push in the center gives some
air to the black pieces and it looks
like origin he decides to hop for with
his Knight he's keeping the tension
that's something very instructive in
chess you don't release the tension
until the moment you feel is ready
because you don't just want to take a
piece as it is simply offered but it
this does give black the opportunity to
push that Central Pawn forward and
create an attack towards the white king
so it's going to be an interesting
battle here I think just the type of
position and that alireza could hope for
out of the London system yeah and the
debate is always as Robert mentions when
to push this Pawn forward or if to push
this Pawn forward because yes you can
gain some time actually he doesn't go
for this he captures the pawn but uh
after the White Knight steps back the
dark Square Bishop the London Bishop
actually gains in power gains an
influence along this diagonal long term
and unless you can actually go for this
King and Checkmate it then often this is
something that may backfire instead
farouza slightly surprisingly to me
captures this Pawn this is something we
don't often see uh in the London system
too much now white I'm assuming will
recapture it this way and there will be
a semi-open C file for the white Rook
later still the same issue of this dark
Square Bishop having a watchful gaze
over this diagonal this does happen and
version says okay you've got a slightly
more open position now I'm going to lock
down the queen side I'm going to fix the
pawn structure here Lex pawns are going
to stay in this formation for I think uh
forever if they can and plate will
switch towards the central squares black
is maybe going to plant a knight on this
nice E4 square and start pushing some
pawns towards the white king from your
London experience London system
experience guys uh what do you think is
this
well who's this gonna favor at this
point rate I'm surprised I must say
like what alireza has done with this
Pawn trade and I think it was uh it was
encouraged by White's move pushing that
a pawn to A4 and this is the point that
I was going to make David that the
Knight can't jump to B4 as well because
white spawn has all all the way gone up
to A4 you don't have to move A3 pushing
that Knight so the B4 square is a super
nice Square for your knight to land on
so yes you want to trade in the center
forcing white while not forcing when
white wants to pick that pawn up with
the c Pawn as he did but in that bargain
you kind of give up control over this B4
square and that's what alireza is
fighting for so a nice idea there okay
interesting stuff although I might say
that the pawn push that other is made to
push the pawn to A5 I think that gave
white some ground because just like
you're bringing the Knight into B4 white
can bring the Knight via A3 up to B5 and
the big problem for black is you can't
touch either the c or the d-pawn if you
push the C Pawn you lose the pawn on D6
if you push the d-pawn eventually up to
D5 if the Knight moves out the way then
C7 will be a quick Target so I feel like
that move A5 was one of those just small
moves that has a big consequence
consequences for both sides certainly
and uh let's go back to the place I do
expect them because this is a more
maneuvering type of battle to spend
quite a lot of time I do notice
especially in the rapid format players
tend to invest their time when there's
lots of different plans to choose from
when it comes to calculation they're so
quick that they make decisions very very
fast and they're usually right so here
where there's no right or wrong answer
where it's just a matter of taste a
matter of style and they do tend to tank
for a while so Eric I see now down three
minutes on the clock this is kind of a
reverse of the first game between these
guys when it was far Asia and his clock
handling that cost him but wow peace
sacrifice and Tanya your first instinct
was what he's given up a bishop he's
London Bishop for two Pawns that is the
bishop that you you just love this is
the reason you play the London and he
gives it up well the idea is clear
you're hitting that Rook on E8 you're
hitting that Bishop on B7 uh and black
has to answer the question has to give
back some material here do you there's
one interesting idea that does exist
Queen B8 defending that saying that you
take the bishop you take the Rook on it
but I get two pieces in return and it
looks like it might be enough for black
I am shocked at this decision David yeah
and if we do a quick count now we do see
that white has parted with a bishop a
knight that's worth six points black
however has plotted with a rook and two
pawns with seven so kind of if we do a
bit of maths why it should be ahead but
top chess players they often prefer the
pieces rather than the rook and pawns
here White's Rooks one of them is okay
on the Open Sea file the other one fast
asleep at home white pawns can't really
advance and often it actually helps
having more pieces here black having the
nine and Bishop because uh if you do
whip up an attack later on two pieces uh
will be better than one and Robert what
do you think of this committal decision
by white well Big Choice from originary
guys tonight I'm used to trusting him
he's such a strong player that he would
not make the sacrifice he hadn't looked
at a similar type of sacrifice in the
past but what we're saying certainly
holds true that the two minor pieces can
team up on a square or on a piece and
Rook is only one piece it's gonna be
difficult to defend so for now I like
White's position I think everything is
nice and neat but I could see a future
where black just improves piece by piece
and then white will not be able to deal
with it because there are no more
Targets in Black's position what are you
going to go after everything is safe and
sound so I do feel like as this game
continues its side who has the better
plan that is gonna have the advantage
yeah so this one despite the evaluation
bar being roughly in the middle it could
go either way later on and
I I kind of love and hate that decision
I hate it because I would never be brave
enough to play something like this
myself because it now it's so imbalanced
it's so complex but I also love it from
a Fan's point of view because this one
is going to be anything but a draw this
one it could go either way especially if
as we predict is very likely at this
point Black's pieces do start to improve
do start to mobilize and whites Rock if
it can't use the openc file uh it will
feel uh like a bit of a silly piece so
yeah all to play for in this one I like
to play fun black needs to watch out
because white has got a devious threat
right now because white wants to push
off that Knight on D5 with the move like
E4 notice how The Queen 98 cannot pick
up that pawn on e4 because the Knight on
D7 is hanging and uh then you'll be
forced to move that Knight and White
Strip can jump to C7 which is why
alireza takes the decision to move the
Rook to the center of the board
defending the D7 Knight so that if you
do go E4 now the black queen is free to
capture the pawn yeah it's free to
capture the pawn and importantly the
Knight is defended so yeah hidden threat
that I actually missed that one Tanya
but of course these top players they do
spot those ideas and nice defensive move
there from farrugia if we're talking
about white improving pieces maybe you
can finally utilize this Rook try to
start motoring your pawns up the board
you have to use your pawns remember you
do have two more of them uh if you're
white here than black does but it's not
going to be easy for example if you do
move the Rook to support a pawn push
black can clamp down on that one maybe
push the F Pawn to control that square
maybe occupy that square with the queen
a bunch of options and uh yeah it's hard
as we mentioned to get this Rook into
its dream post on C7 for now because
it's protected by a knight but watch out
for Eric I see trying to tactically
enable that maneuver a bit later on so
we are expecting this now to be an
interesting battle I was gonna ask right
before Air Guys he made those huge
decisions if we should switch games
because I could see on the bars in the
other games that may baby Magnus Carlsen
is struggling against Alexa sorana if
you've seen that game Robert he is I was
looking at the game at the corner of my
eye and for Magnus Carlson he won with
the white piece in game one very
convincingly here in game two it looks
like Serana if you if you didn't show
the audience who had what color you
might think that Magnus Carlsen had the
white pieces because it's just a clear
Advantage for Alexa he is playing very
well in the second game all right and uh
Hikaru Nakamura though the bar all the
way uh well it's over to his side
against yukashi won the first game
Hikaru Nakamura and you guys shout out
if we have to switch games but it does
sound like there will be a lot of action
in this one it feels like for now this
is the place to be but we will keep uh
keep you guys updated I should also
mention with Serana in the play-ins he
went seven for seven with white wow and
in the world Blitz he beat Nakamura and
Carlson with white so those are the
games he's banking on he's relying on he
needs to win those ones uh with black as
we saw in in game one of the day
he does struggle a bit he didn't score
so well and his black repertoire maybe
not sir as bulletproof as uh he is with
the white pieces and Carlson just wants
to survive that one but it's going to be
an uphill task Serana doing very well
and Serana is known to be a beast with
the white pieces his preparation the way
he plays once he gets the initiative so
it's definitely going to be a tough one
for Magnus and looking at what we have
in front of us I think it's going to be
a tough one for alireza as well I love
the idea that you mentioned earlier
David of bringing the Rook into the
center of the board with rookie one and
it's been played the idea is simple you
really want to land that sea Rook on C7
you want to hit that Bishop the pin
Knight on D7 E4 is a massive threat on
the board and if black does bring the
queen all the way forward to the Central
Square stopping that white can make a
retreating move with the Knight hit that
Queen on e4 and force it back and get
that Central Pawn moving this can be big
pressure for black yeah if these two
pawns land uh on e4 and D4 they control
all the squares they neutralize the
vision of those black minor pieces they
really take away some squares the
knights aren't necessarily on great
circuits right now okay you can plant a
knight on a nice Outpost but suddenly
boom The Rook lands on the seventh Rank
and disaster for black uh potentially
yeah suddenly big questions to answer
for for sure I think a big question is
why he made his previous move uh the
position is one that is very complicated
so we don't want to be overly critical
but H6 just kind of a casual Pawn push
in a position that's getting very messy
a loud white the time to bring the Rook
to E1 and push this Pawn up in the
center kicking away Black's minor pieces
so I think that H6 was just a little bit
too slow in the position he probably
should have moved his Queen up out of
the pin and that way his Knights could
be a bit more free so I just think that
that last move from fridges one he'll
regret yeah you can't play Slow moves
you don't have that luxury in these
types of positions and maybe that's just
a bit of rust from frosher it feels like
he's not quite at his best yet in terms
of uh kind of the energetic play that
we're used to seeing from him but uh
will he find a justification for that
strange Pawn push this is the current
position after white moves The Rook uh
to E1 and big threat on the board he
needs to solve it he needs to find an
antidote and okay nine minutes for
version eight minutes for a Regice this
one still in the balance for now but
black the one under pressure
we do have some questions coming in on
Twitter with some viewers using the
hashtag chess Champs there is a question
for you actually now Tanya
um and I bet this is from a fan in India
wondering what chances you give origin
of winning the whole thing
well you know as commentators we're
supposed to be not bad I'm gonna admit
that I was super happy to see two
Indians make it to this first division
of the first ever double elimination
bracket that we've got we had six spots
up for qualification and gaucasian Arjun
both made it to the top amazing and in a
great way in the playoffs I think Arjun
you know he's had such a meteoric rise
he was around 2500 and then over a
period of a year he gained about a
hundred points went on to play in the
Champions Chester in a brilliant way at
the Tata steel chess India rapid and
Blitz who would have thought that he
would have won the championship he won
the rapid uh lost in the playoff in the
blitz finish second so I think he's
definitely someone to watch out for now
when you've got players like Hikaru and
Magnus and Wesley playing you know it's
not going to be easy but in my heart I
am rooting for Arjun and gokish there I
said it
you're very loud too very loud
definitely well Tanya you must be happy
to see the last move on the board
because the evaluation bars reacted in
arjun's favor wow we need to figure out
why now which is less clear maybe but
it's looking good for white David I
understand the more Rook see it we've
been screaming about this idea of E4 and
getting that Rook to C7 so alireza tries
to challenge that open Rook on the C5
but the one thing that stands out is now
the Knight on D7 is just super tender
if you're able to build up an attack on
that that would be bad news yeah this
would be terrible news if we can put
pressure on this D7 Knight looks
difficult at the moment I'm wondering
whether you can for example trade off
one set of Rooks actually I was told
that especially in these imbalances
Rooks versus minor pieces you want to
have one of everything it's like ice
cream flavors once your opponent doesn't
have any Rooks anymore here black
doesn't have any Rooks suddenly you
become very tender on certain squares
and especially if the white Rook gets
into the game and now I'm wondering do
you push the pawn up maybe you switch
the bishop back onto this diagonal maybe
this would be a nasty threat for black
to deal with actually now I look at it
this looks devastating and okay he
doesn't go for this era Galaxy I was
going to say now the Knight can be
defended yes for example you can back it
up with another Knight but finally
overpower the knight in the center once
it moves white breaks through on the
diagonal you winner the second well
third Point sorry and uh this looks
crushing almost and uh Robert instead
he's gone for something else he's missed
this opportunity and played E4 is this
equally strong I think it's a case of
mutual oversight which had so much focus
on the C file and the pin on the Knight
on D7 that looking at the F7 Square
being tender was kind of out of their
mind so I get why both players miss it
there's just so much else going on but a
missed opportunity there for Arden his
position still looks very good if you
can push your Pawns in the center you
have two extra pawns you want to make
use of them you're limiting the scope of
your enemy's pieces but the more your
pawns move up the board it's one of
those Bishops might end up thriving so
it's a double-edged position and I think
alireza now he all of a sudden with a
knight in enemy camp he can be feeling a
little bit better even if he objectively
is worse here yep he's struggling but he
does have this one very active piece and
uh yeah you want to kick it out you want
to get rid of it as soon as possible
thus uh Eric I see it comes over swings
his Queen and drives the Knight back he
is pushing this piece back if it has to
retreat momentum white yet again so it's
still looking good for aragaisy maybe
not as good as it could have been he
could have won another Pawn to add to
this collection but uh still very strong
and for Asia is having to contort
himself play some odd looking is now
pushing a pawn to G5 that's very
weakening very loose that type of move
it needed to happen though it needed to
be done and he's Clinging On to active
squares for his pieces there is a bit of
a difference building up on the clock a
Regice certainly spending a lot longer
in this game than he did on the previous
attacking Masterpiece uh from game one
but uh if he speeds up he's still doing
very well Tanya still cheering for him
100 I Arjun realizes that he's he should
be better in this position as long as he
keeps those minor pieces that black has
under control the pawn structure in the
center takes away so many key squares
that Bishop on B5 pinning down that
Knight on D7 so he knows the position's
good but he can't slow down he has to
make sure that he keeps up the pressure
now Black's last move the pawn pushed to
G5 it controls his own Knight on F4 but
does give up the F5 square and I was I
was thinking about this that land
something on H4 I was wondering if the
Knight can go on H4 but Arjun comes up
with another idea David of trying to
break that pawn chain and I look at our
valbar it doesn't love the move but from
a human perspective I think it's very
strong yeah certainly asking really
difficult questions uh of version right
now how do you defend that pawn that's
just been attacked on G5 if that porn
ever gets dislodged then the Black
Knight Falls and
difficult suddenly it does feel like
you're being overwhelmed over kind of
stretched your defenses the black queen
is tied down she's looking in so many
different directions she needs to defend
her Knight her rook and she can't kind
of swing to the defense of her King
I'm struggling to find moves here as
black I've got to say I think he's gonna
have the slightest Queen one square over
to the starting Square either after The
Rook trade or in the current position
and that way you defend this Pawn on G5
tactics May favor the side with more
pieces on the board and black has two
minor pieces for a rook so the queen may
be overloaded but if you start some
trades perhaps it's blacks pieces that
go into the position and start creating
attacks and the white king is the one
that actually lacks shelter yep I want
to point out one interesting tactic that
exists in the position that the players
need to watch out for after H4 we are
looking at this line with Rook takes he
won the trade on C1 and David you're
pointing out that white picks it up with
The Rook which is such an action move
and black does have the opportunity once
you do that to actually capture the pawn
on e4 because look at the geometry with
that Knight on F4 targeting the E2
Square where it can Fork the king and
the Rook you can allow the Knight on D7
to be hanging because the bishop on B5
needs to defend the E2 Square uh and I
think the tactics just seem to be
working out and look at this Rook C1 on
the board and Arjun needs to to be
careful now yeah this could happen this
variation you mentioned a night check
Landing it's four or five moves in the
future but the fact that Eric icy has
post means it's on his radar this is not
going to happen David yeah I think
you're right uh but we needed to show
that it's a it's kind of a potential
slip up here for arigaity if he takes
with the Rook things will turn around in
Black's favor as you mentioned that
Tanya Queen takes porn would be
extremely strong picking off one of
White's kind of Pride prized possessions
there in the center but the fact he has
stopped means he's going to calculate
and he's going to realize he has to take
with the queen and now you definitely
don't want to take this Pawn with the
bishop because uh you walk into a pin on
the e-file end there we go you predicted
it it does take with the queen and still
in the balance but Black's Queen now
getting active at least creating some
threats Robert mentioned it a couple of
moves ago potentially the white king
couldn't come under Fire oh my goodness
this is one of those positions where the
evaluation bar does not tell the story
we see objectively white is better with
the best moves operative word being best
it's difficult to make great moves when
that Queen is sliding up to the G4
Square two squares in the diagonal
towards the white king and those
checkmating threats immediately and it's
the only way to stop Checkmate is by
pushing that pawn in front of your king
you almost never want to push Pawns in
front of your king of it opens up
diagonals it creates weak squares and
blacks forced about to hop right in this
could be big trouble if our generic icy
does not show pinpoint accuracy yeah and
it's going to be difficult to show that
type of accuracy with only three minutes
on the clock minimal increment coming on
per move okay he takes support but this
is really playing with fire we've got to
say the black queen is poised she's
ready to jump in I'm not sure whether
she will immediately but that threat
will stay on the cards for the next few
moves there's all sorts of captures here
the Black Knight can even take a Pawn on
G2 have to work out the consequences
there worse comes to worst for ferrugia
you just take this Pawn back the white
Pawn on G5 and you say okay the tactics
are still in the air I'll make you think
I'll make you calculate a bit more the
fact the evaluation bar hasn't reacted
means that maybe there's no knockout
blow for black and maybe no tactics work
right now but that's what Ferris is
going to spend his remaining time on
he's going to spend a while trying to
figure out whether he can go for that
white king immediately this is such a
brave decision by Arjun to take on G5 I
mean if I was white I would see Knight
takes cheat too with the queen coming in
with the check and I wouldn't have the
heart to go for it and alireza brings up
the queen first attacking threatening
amid in one on the board Arjun
immediately blitzes out G3 so he has
calculated this very important defense
where yes black can pick up the Knight
on F3 but then white goes on to win the
Knight on F4
it's lucky that White's Queen is sitting
there uh watching from afar to defend
her King uh the White Queen would swoop
into defend just in time in this
variation so for Russia can't go for
this he lands a check the king moves and
now the question is can he get to this
white king or not if he can't then
there's a bunch of problems you've got
too many pawns uh now you've given up
too many pawns to go for this attack
also this Knight is under Fire so
farouza I'm surprised he went for that
queen move so quickly he just recaptures
on G5 and he keeps the momentum flowing
huge threat Knight H3 back to F4 is the
threat you need the pawn on G5 because
without that pawn there the queen on C1
would capture the Knight now it is
defended the G3 Pawn is pinned to the
white king that's a huge threat so maybe
at this point uh White has to start
backtracking and then Knight on F3 it
looks like it's on a good square but
maybe it has to drop back to H2 kick
that Queen out of there keep it safe and
sound but I'm looking at this position
and I feel like with arjun's time in
particular it's looking really scary
despite the fact that he is object
actually better I think you have to
balance the position with the clock yeah
there's all sorts of calculation to do
here either the black queen can move you
can maybe even snag a Pawn on e4 and
calculate a whole bunch of checks it's
getting chaotic let's Let The Players
try and figure out what's happening here
I don't think we'll see in uh an
error-free game from this point because
it's so easy to go wrong I think at some
point someone's going to make a mistake
and and uh it's just about who makes the
last mistake as it gets even more
chaotic first I think Robert's right
Eric icy needs to take defensive
measures he needs to move that white
knight before it's too late can Arjun
allow himself more than a minute the
thinking pause now some positions you
can survive on a minute it doesn't feel
like this is one of them oh wow and he
brought the notebook and look at how
quickly other Scoops up the pawn with
check against that white king So if you
decide to push your Pawn up to F3 guys I
think we're gonna see another Sacrifice
from alirez he's gonna keep giving away
pieces exposing the white king yeah we
have to show this because this would end
in some cool little tactics cool night
jumps uh this would be the most natural
move for white blocking a check looks
like you're forking two pieces here
attacking the bishop attacking the queen
but Bishop takes Pawn would be pretty
much obligatory here and after a
recapture the Black Knight jumps back
with a nasty check and uh when the king
moves could we see a little dance
between the knight and king maybe we'll
see another Knight check the white king
would have to jump out into the open if
it wants to avoid a draw here uh
repetition may be uh the most logical
finish instead a Regice he doesn't want
just to draw he doesn't want that to
repeat he gave up his Rook for the
bishop in the center and now he's
captured this Black Knight on the edge
of the board so it's now a completely
different assortment of material it's
one point in White's favor but his King
is on the edge of the board precarious
stuff oh my goodness white desperately
wants to trade off the Queens because if
we actually do a quick material count a
white has Five Pawns black only has four
so the Queens just disappear white has
extra material the presence of opposite
colored Bishops that's important to
store in your backpack and in your
memory bank because that means with the
queen trade it's likely the resulting
Position will be a game where the point
of split a draw looks the likeliest
outcome but the Queens are still on the
white king is out on in the open on H3
that could be really dangerous
especially with the clock ticking down
yep on every guy see side here however
pieces are coming off the board so it
will be slightly easier to navigate with
no time on the clock he's attacking this
Knight he's attacking this pawn and I
think for now there's not enough
attackers around the white king to take
advantage of its uh positioning so this
is uh almost no time to breathe in this
game I'm so impressed that farrugia has
found his way through these
complications still with four and a half
minutes on his clock because there were
so many options so many twists and turns
uh just in that last tactical sequence
but we've emerged with this position and
yeah Eric Garcia would love an end game
he's not going to be given one however
for Russia is going to keep going for
that white king what do you think will
be the results right now in this game
will we see a winner will it be a draw
what do you think
is so tough to answer because this
position is literally playing for all
results everything is possible and it
looks like yes uh draw might be a likely
outcome but the path to that draw is
going to be super risky Anything Can
Happen one of the ideas that comes to
mind for alireza is to give a check on
F5 you were mentioning the pawn on G5 is
attacked the Knight on D7 is attacked a
check on F5 would defend and guard both
these undefended pieces but alireza
doesn't care about defense he wants to
pick up that Central Pawn he goes for it
but in return has to give up this very
key Pawn I said draw is a likely result
cut that out I think that despite the
material deficit that Alvarez is playing
for a win he's saying we have Bishops
opposite colors in the end game that
made me in a draw but when you're
attacking I mean you can't actually
Parry off my Bishop it's on the dark
squares years in the light squares then
Knight on C5 trying to hop into the E4
square right next to the queen just
going towards the enemy King this could
be difficult for Arjuna geisey remember
there's only a three second increment
and he is down towards his final minimum
the clock oh yeah yeah so easy to go
wrong here he brings his Knight forward
that's a defensive maneuver as well as
an attacking idea he's just guarding
that white F2 pawn and uh also hinting
that he might jump forward with some
nasty checks towards the black king
suddenly farooja has to find an equally
multi-purpose move perhaps he needs to
go for that white king but he also needs
to keep watchful eye over his King yeah
opposite color Bishops I've always found
those the most difficult positions to
evaluate to handle because it's never
clear who's attacking who's on the
defensive and I think both sides are
playing for the win here they were both
uh want to push this one uh even further
and okay first in an attack against the
White Queen
the Black Knight sitting on a really
nice Square I've got to say and I'm just
trying to look for safe squares for her
for her majesty here the White Queen
does find one on F5 but uh okay Black's
Queen if she could somehow land herself
behind the white king Imagine The Black
Queen on the bottom right hand corner of
the board on H1 there would be
devastating threats there so uh what is
going to go for he could also be greedy
here and take time out to grab that
white Pawn on B2 but it doesn't feel too
relevant right now so I would be
slightly surprised to see that one and
it allowed that Bishop which has been
sitting on B5 forever before it was
pinning a knight now it's doing nothing
except for staring in thin air if that
Bishop can slide back onto a new
diagonal staring towards the black king
right that Bishop gets the C4 you're
hitting the Knight and the F7 Pawn
behind it that could be really
problematic for alireza farusia so he
should not look at the clock and think
I'm gonna go flag origin era guys this
is one of the best bullet chess players
in the world I mentioned earlier he won
the junior speed chess championship by
taking out nihal sarin everybody should
know nihal siren for being the runner-up
in the global Championship so you don't
want to just look at the clock he needs
to play the board here and he has
brought his Queen D1 looking at David's
plan of going over to the H1 square but
it seems like it was a mistake look at
the bar whoa yeah what is happening here
maybe white can just ignore this I
thought it was a killer threat but
White's Knight is just about able to
jump back and defend so right now maybe
there's a killer move and wow look at
what other guys he's done uh I wasn't
gonna I wasn't 100 sure about suggesting
this one but I regassi was very
confident here he lands his Bishop on
this diagonal that Robert was mentioning
and what version might have missed is
that any check from behind looks like
Checkmate but White's Knight can just
jump back and defend suddenly the black
queen is offside she's in no man's land
she doesn't want to be on this side of
the board she's needed as a Defender and
huge threats against the black King
instead
wow maybe sorry uh go on tonight finish
your furniture I was gonna say mate was
just a bit of a bluff life for Russia
and now he's regretting it yeah we saw
that little head shake by farouja there
I think he completely missed the fact
that Queen H1 is not a Checkmate and
after the Knight comes back to H2 you
realize that Knights are not only great
attackers but also really good Defenders
you see how it controls all the squares
around the king there are no checks on
the board Bishop E6 is a massive threat
yes you can fall back with your queen to
C6 now to try and defend that Knight on
E6 but now black has run out of fire
completely no threats against white king
uh White simply makes a move like B3
gods that Bishop on C4 and White's
dominating yeah well it's dominating the
Knight can come back to a more active
Square later black is completely Frozen
uh once you have to go on the defensive
that will only spell bad news and you
are Pawn down to boots so not a great
turn in this game for ferrugia he's
looking really downcast you see him on
the camera head in hands now uh his last
move was a bit of a complacent one
perhaps for sure because if you're going
to be a pawn down in some positions you
want the opposite colored Bishops an
added bonus of having this bishop on C4
is that some moment the right moment
we'll see Arjun take that Knight on E6
and enter a position with Knight versus
Bishop that extra Pawn will tell the
story so I'll raise it he's on the
defensive he's on his back foot he
brings his Quint all the way back to C6
A3 David your suggestion is great simple
strong defending everything yep you
could make an argument maybe for taking
that black knight right now but uh I
don't think there's any Rush that there
we go B3 on the board the most natural
move that black knight is not going
anywhere it's an easy target for White's
Bishop White's Bishop is now far far
superior to its counterpart we were
talking about the opposite color Bishops
the color complexes there's so many
targets for that white Bishop there's no
targets for the black Bishop it's
hitting thinner and uh you know it's
turning in White's favor and white is
still an extra Pawn up you've got that
material advantage you're out of danger
with your own King the Knight jumping
back into the attack you might dissolve
the problem of the opposite color
Bishops these endings are always known
to be a bit joyous but that might not be
the case once the bishop and the Knights
are traded off this looks like Arjun
could be headed towards a second Victory
but of course alireza is going to make
that super hard and he moves the night
away but look at the clocks both players
are on the 32nd Mark and that is
dangerous territory look at this play by
origin centralizing the bishop no more
Queen H1s for you he's going to be able
to bring his Knight back into the game
next in event Knight hops forward into
the enemy territory there could be
Checkmate threats yeah we'll see that
white knight get back into the action
leap back there and also this pattern
between the white bishop and the Black
Knight last year Simon Williams the
ginger Jam he called it the night stable
the Knight is locked at home can never
move without being captured by that
white Bishop it's Total Domination and
wow Eric I see he just takes a time out
to keep his Kings safe that white king
now super safe in its Palace there
surrounded by pawns Black's King has
fewer Defenders around it this one is
certainly heading towards a white wind
right now he just needs to get his
Knight maybe to a more active square but
uh faruja clinging on for dear life and
uh yeah how are you guys at bullet chest
this is under 20 seconds for both
players it's getting nerve-wracking now
but look at Arjuna he doesn't look
nervous at all and this is what I've
always admired about him that in the
face of extreme time pressure just the
best in him comes out he's still we can
see with the valbar making the best
moves keeping his pieces centralized
keeps everything protected this is some
great advice by the way uh that whenever
you're low on the clock just make sure
that everything's protected the bishop
on C4 is guarded by the B3 Pawn the
Queen's guarded by the king the knights
defended everything under control whoa
everything under control but suddenly
the position has changed there were two
or three very very quick moves there and
suddenly for Russia has grabbed a pawn
that white Pawn on F2 was captured by
the black Bishop the White Queen is
overloaded having to defend her own
Bishop in the center couldn't take that
black Bishop Now Pawn is dropped near
the black king it's total chaos despite
the reduced material and Black's King is
on the run but that night on D.A do not
take it with the nine F7 that that's a
very bad piece you'd much I thought it
was night back to E5 would check and say
that night is dominated on the back row
instead he brings a queen in with check
I feel like the black king is Slithering
away and that gives Ali reason increased
chances to survive yeah and it feels
like every guy see the nerves are
kicking in he's giving a few checks to
gain time on the incremental 28 now yeah
he's attacked the diagonal this check
can be blocked by Black's Bishop the
black Bishop slid back to block and
still a dance between the white king uh
White Queen and the black king version
leaning back though and it's over he won
peace he won a piece the black king now
cannot take that white knight because
then you lose your bishop and every guy
see we almost missed it there but spun
it in his favor and there's no check on
the white king the black king overloaded
and this is just game over what a finish
and that we have a result we've got two
zero by origin he takes a massive lead
wow RJ and Eric I see what a player he
goes up by two points and that means
otherwise he's gonna be in a must-win
situation in game three to have a chance
of winning the match what a day he's
having Arjun eragaisi winning game two I
did see Magnus Carlsen he did as well
win game number two going up two points
in his match an AC car Nakamura about to
do the same and this is not the position
from this game this is the position from
game one of the day so uh hopefully we
can get an update of Refresh on that
board it looks like okay Hikaru leaning
back he did just take the win and uh
hopefully we'll get a chance to see the
final position there but I can confirm
kakesh has just resigned in that game it
was a similar final position where hikar
nakumar won an end game so the game
lasted quite a while but two games in a
row it's Al Hikaru wow so we have three
players now up by two points and their
matches some incredible chests going on
today in the air things monsters we did
follow game two with our generic IC and
Ali rest of Russia can you give us the
highlights David how is Arjun able to
win that game yeah I just want to show a
few moments because it went so quickly
at the end it was fast it was Furious
and it all started around here farusha
actually spotted a really cunning tactic
as black we knew he was a pawn down we
knew the black king was in some danger
but he spotted he could grab this F2
Pawn uh this white F2 Pawn because the
White Queen cannot step back and capture
suddenly the white Bishop would
disappear everything would be equal and
ferrugia would save the game instead
Eric he went on the counter attack he
took a port near the black king the what
black Bishop retreated and we were
saying there are a bunch of checks here
very tempting checks but don't trade off
pieces don't trade the knights that
would lead perhaps towards a draw and uh
with a bunch of clever checks continuing
to chase the black king he found this
maneuver checking the King on the
diagonal maybe ferocious mistake was to
not go this way I'm surprised he didn't
run towards safety on this side of the
board instead he stepped towards the
center and after a few more checks we
see the killer blow a queen check on F5
hitting the king hitting the bishop and
when the king defended its Bishop
suddenly Knight takes Knight no
salvation anymore black has zero checks
no way to counter attack and if the
black king takes the White Knight the
bishop Falls game over Eric I see two
nil up
[Music]
foreign
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything this chapter
is about
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
92 of games get to this position from
this
these 70 of the time and I think if you
learn these lines that very easily could
be 75 or 80 for you
[Music]
is joining me in the studio to talk
about this new exciting season of the
Champions Chester but if you're not yet
a subscriber on Twitch we're going to
send you to a twitch break now
[Music]
I still call you tour director Arnold
but you actually have a new title what
is it very long it's hard to say my
brother we can I'm here now as the head
of temperatures through production head
of Champions chess tour of production it
is the first day of the air things
Masters uh the event the first day of
the 2023 season how are you doing are
you excited I'm so excited so
amazing to finally be on the road again
with this new exciting format in this
new environment that we're part of now
so this is really cool yeah and there's
so much new stuff to the Champions chess
tour
um what is the the idea behind the whole
new format uh the idea is to take the
best from both worlds from the play
Magnus world and hs.com world cheers.com
who has this amazing reach play Magnus
who has been working a lot of innovation
on how to distribute chess and see how
we can really take the best from both
worlds and make this the most exciting
tour for everyone to follow yeah what
would you say is the biggest difference
from the two first season to the 2023
season first of all that we have all the
big names being able to participate in
this we have an amazing prize fund we
have an amazing reach and also the fact
that we are going from invited players
now to a full open system of qualifiers
which mean that everybody who really has
it in them to be a part of the tour can
in theory qualify and the goal though it
must still be the same to grow chess to
a wider audience grow the game make just
more interesting accessible and viewable
for wider Audits and now with the
amazing boom that just has Now is really
the time also for us to work on this to
create a concept together both
consecrated tour that is incredibly
exciting both for those who love chess
already but also for all those new fans
getting new glasses over the game yeah
and you've been a part of this from the
very start the actually from the very
start when I was called the Magnus
Carlsen imitational Invitational I think
yeah a couple years ago kovid hit the
Champions chess tour was born and now
it's growing even bigger even better
what is it like to be a part of it it's
it's it's amazing you have to pinch your
arm and you have to take it one step
back and actually think about what we
all are a part of right now the
incredible boom that's happening in the
interest of Jess and that it just keeps
on growing and what we all the
opportunities that we have ahead of us
now is is really really amazing yeah and
we know these first days always hectic
have you been able to follow any of the
chess
a little bit what do you think about the
level the action the players are
bringing so far it's uh it's really cool
to see it it's uh it's it's so many new
elements now in the first day of a
broadcast that there's a lot of things
to to put together to make sure
everything fits but uh what I've been
able to watch so far has been really
amazing
and something else that is new is uh the
panel here in the Oslo studio with Tanya
and Robert now joining uh David and
myself in the studio and Ivanka and when
everyone when anyone new comes to Norway
we have to give them a cold welcome
come on Tanya come on in
what's the worst thing that can happen
to someone nothing you have a steal put
this in there we buff a little bit here
oh come on we'll be fine
[Music]
Slayer Magnus Carlsen uh I feel like
Bambi are nice but we've got no excuse
we're going to win team England team
England versus team global we're gonna
challenge you guys in a cross country
oh my God
[Applause]
not so easy to I Will Survive
[Music]
you can do this
coming home Tanya you got this unlike
the Terminator I'm coming up oh my God I
got himself
[Music]
foreign
so we're done with the skiing Robert and
Tanya did take the win but now we're
back in our natural habitat at the good
night chess Pub and Ivanka and I we have
a chance for Revenge
this Castle from safety
[Music]
so sneaky
oh my gosh what is that
[Music]
all right we got this we got this we got
this
how
okay nice move
under pressure yes
oh
[Music]
my God
the good night
[Music]
if we've gone the other way
I'm over here still yeah it's okay Queen
C6 was so true
[Music]
all right
we have to give a shout out to Puma for
dressing up our experts in their new
very cool Four Seasons collection so you
were comfortable clothing wise how did
you feel on those keys Tanya
petrified I was petrified on the skis as
was pretty Apparent from the video but I
have to admit that my heart was beating
faster when we were playing the chess
really
we were excellent it's a lot of fun it
was a lot of fun and uh I know I started
like an absolute disaster on those skis
but by the end of it I actually loved it
and you got the hang of it I'm very
impressed and David you are I've said to
you so many times the most competitive
person I know you were very upset after
losing that battle I don't want to talk
about it it was a fix it was it
but uh it was a lot of fun and congrats
to these two it's all my fault though
Ivanka was awesome uh I just let us down
in both the skiing and the chest yeah
good start for team global in the Oslo
Studio
nice all right and it's a good start
especially for three players in the air
things monsters these are the results
after two games so far Magnus Carlsen is
up by two points that means I like say
Serana he has to win game three to take
it to a game four situation is the same
for you cash in the most win situation
in game three Hikaru Nakamura is up by
two points and so is Arjun Eric icy
winning two games in a row against
alireza Russia Wesley so and Ralph Mama
though they have played two draws and
they are tied so far so Robert who's
impressed you the most so far today it
has to be our generic I see because
Magnus Carlson Hikaru Nakamura they're
always the favorite unless they're
playing each other in which case the
toss-up but for our generic garci he's
been unbelievable he's finding the
tactics even when he's down on time he's
still playing the best moves and he
earned himself those two wins definitely
we're gonna follow the next game between
Hikaru Nakamura and yukash with yukash
being in a must win situation Hikaru on
fire today so what is it about for the
16 year old Indian right now Tanya
he had a phenomenal run at the
qualifiers in the Swiss plane he
finished right at the top and then very
strategic bold decision of playing
against Vladimir kramnik in the playoff
and 1.0 and then what he gets as a prize
is a first round matchup against Hikaru
Nakamura an absolute Beast a monster in
this format and undoubtedly Hikaru is a
big favorite and he's showing us why uh
cookies has to win on demand he has to
give this next game everything and more
it's a tough task ahead of him yeah
it's twin situation for three players we
couldn't have asked for a more dramatic
start to the Champions chess tour 2023
and here we go game three you cash with
the white pieces uh we should have asked
for another prediction from Ukiah you
would have got it right again another
default and no Queen's Gambit here and
Nakamura which opening will he choose of
course he plays Everything Under the Sun
Nakamura he tends to go towards the
Queen's gamber declined when he's in
doubt when he just wants a solid
position for kakesh it's not just about
getting out of the opening it's about
getting out of the opening with a bunch
of pieces left with a very tense
position I do feel that the only way to
beat Nakamura for get cash now will be
to attack him somehow the end game has
proven to be uh nakamura's forte in this
matchup today at least and it's another
London system though so uh do we Boo
this one or do we think it's a great
match strategy for good cash well you
mentioned he needs to keep all the
pieces on the board so from that
approach I think it makes a lot of sense
you're hoping for the a long game here
Hikaru needs just a draw to wrap up this
match so it's definitely a tough task
ahead of the cage he's going to throw
everything he's got he starts slow one
of the things that players often end up
doing in a must-win situation is play
these rash openings and they don't end
well so I like that gauquacious at least
kept calm and chosen this line which
kind of gives him the opportunity to get
a middle game to just play for a normal
game and hopefully not get into an end
game like you're mentioning yeah he's
going to keep all the pieces on the
board this is uh rare sideline of the
London system where white has had to
commit a move to playing them to playing
Rook B1 just defending that b-pawn
Black's Queen coming out early that
comes with some risk involved but at
least white does get the time to set up
this triangle of Pawns supporting the
London Bishop but wow Nakamura trading
off the light Squad Bishops looks like a
French defense gone right for black very
right the bad piece for black and French
is that light Square Bishop but I know
Simon Williams Jr GM he always loves
these lines of the bishop sliding out to
D7 then to B5 offering a trade and that
means that the pawn structure is very
solid for black F7 e6d5 great foundation
in the center uh for uh Hikaru Here and
Now The Bishop's out of the way he can
then develop his Knight and keep
everything under control yep it looks
really nice as a bit of a bonus here if
the bishops get traded off black does
prevent the white king from castleing
the queen uses her vision there to
control one of the squares the king
would want to Castle through and of
course you can't Castle through check
you can try and kick the queen away for
example with a move like A4 but the
black queen for example could keep
itself on this diagonal and I'm
struggling to find ways now to keep the
pieces on the board I mentioned that
kokesh ideally wants to keep the tension
he's clearly been surprised in this
opening he's Burnt Over a minute already
it's only moved seven and uh no clear
way to keep the Bishops on apart from
this one wow Pawn to C4 moving the pawn
for a second time in the last two moves
uh he's literally just pushed that pawn
but he moves it again and at the cost of
time at least he'll keep some tension
and I'm not sure now whether he'll take
back with his Knight or his Bishop
either way uh at least he will ask
Nakamura some questions I do fear for
kakash if Nakamura is in home
preparation however it does feel like
the type of position where if you've
done your homework you will be able to
just Hoover off a bunch of pieces and we
see those pieces disappearing uh okay a
queen check a double attack but luckily
white can slide the Knight back to
defend and a bunch more exchanges are
happening what does Nakamura just
reacted to he's talking to himself just
asking himself the question what's
happened he did just take a pawn is this
a mistake maybe he forgot his
preparation looks very natural to me
Robert yeah it's like a completely
normal move so it could be a Hikaru
gesticulating just uh kind of putting on
appearances for the show but at the same
time maybe there is something he didn't
like because sometimes we release the
tension too early that gives the
opponent some extra opportunities of
some freedom for the pieces I think
black's Edition looks great white has an
isolated Pawn so this Pawn on D4 cannot
be defended by another Pawn the good
news inherent to having an iqp isolated
Queen Pawn is the adjacent files are
open so Rook can eventually size the
e-file a rook to the C file that's great
but the Pawn's a perennial Target black
has no risk in the foundation of his
position so I think Hikaru is in
everything you could ask for from from a
player with having the black pieces yep
and uh here white has Castle was saying
okay you can take my Pawn on D4 but it
will come at the cost of time and
Nakamura meanwhile brings his rock
across again not necessarily to even win
this Pawn but to control its advance and
let's go back to the players this one
will result in a very tense middle game
white has the Eternal weakness so needs
to compensate it uh compensate for it
with active play I mean while gokish
trying to kick the black queen out of
his Camp saying get out of here you've
done uh enough you've caused enough
nuisance so far and uh maybe Nakamura
could grab this Pawn in the center next
move if he's feeling greedy remember a
draw suits him though so uh plenty of
solid moves solid Alternatives at his
disposal as well okay
three players are in must win situations
in this round of games gukesh is one of
them can we see that in the way he has
started this game that he's just going
all out
yeah I would say yes he's going for the
London system he's trying to keep peace
on the board but Nakamura hasn't really
allowed him to there's been a trade of
two sets of Pawns one set of minor
pieces
um kukesh I think he goes all out in
every game Kaya that's the thing about
him it's hard to tell when he's playing
solid I don't think I've ever seen good
cash play solid uh he's always very
ambitious and that's why he's already
reached the upper echelons of wild chess
or at such a such a young age and there
is a question there what do you guys
think about kukash's opening choices
Robert well I think that he's playing
what he knows and he needs to take risks
somewhere the problem is in certain
lines that have risk is if somebody has
studied it in which case in this case a
card certainly has figured out this
opening you can combat it in some
forcing ways and that's the last thing
you want in a must win game is to have a
forcing variation that your opponent
knows so at least in the current
position we have white with the bishop
pair only white has a light Square
Bishop whereas black has the two knights
so there is something to play for this
game isn't going to immediately conclude
so I think that I like his choice here
in game three the earlier games I didn't
look into enough depth but I feel like
Hikaru is Hikaru at the end of the day
yeah
yeah and uh Tanya earlier the fans were
asking about Eric icy is the the same
level of support in India for dukesh oh
100 a huge Loveless sport for the Indian
youngsters and gukesh has so far really
shown his class in classical play we had
his breakout performance during the
Olympiad wow what a phenomenal
tournament that was but after that he
had a couple of disappointing results uh
even the Tata steel was his debut but it
was a lukewarm performance at least by
the standards that he sets for himself a
huge learning experience we haven't seen
vocation as much in Rapid and Blitz we
haven't seen him that much in speed
chess which is what made it even more
impressive his run in the qualifiers so
playing against Hikaru here I think this
is a lot to do with experience we were
talking about opening choices I like
that he's gone for the initiative he
doesn't mind giving up that D4 Pawn for
keeping black skin in the center we see
a developing move there by Hikaru not
getting greedy in the center he had no
time to do that allowing checks on the
B5 Square G3 a nice solid move
eventually really what white wants to do
is start pushing the beep on of the
board you want to go B4 you want to get
B5 Now The Rook is on C1 it's x-raying
that Queen on C7 so as far as opening
choices are concerned I think in a
win-on-demand game gukesh has done it
right so far yeah it's hard to get a big
advantage against these top guys in the
world from the opening but he's got all
the pieces still on the board uh most of
the piece is still on the board and
still a lot to play for meanwhile how
are you guys feeling because we can see
the air quality in the studio here
we should be feeling good we should lots
of green there I'm feeling great and
lots of green next to me because Tanya
she wore the good color today and I feel
like you know you can't win them all in
India right now two players in the top
division but you should be pretty happy
origin era garci he is taking down at
least in the first two games uh alireza
fuja and gukesh has a chance here in
game three even though nakamura's
position is very solid and this is why
you're glad that this is a double
elimination bracket I mean there are so
many Indian fans here rooting for
cookies rooting for Arjun and even if
gukesh has a tough spot a tough start in
this match it doesn't mean the end of
the road for him he still has one more
shot at the tournament
yeah so he's guaranteed to be here
tomorrow no matter what definitely and I
mean while gakesh is throwing those
pawns forward before it's too late he
throws his Pawn forward to before
I messed up that pun
okay he's still played B4 and he's
trying to push even further forward to
dislodge those Black Knights and uh yeah
for Nakamura you're Rock Solid you're
controlling the square in front of the
isolated Pawn Black's Knight on the D5
Square looks fantastic you never really
want to trade that off if you're good
cash either because it will come at the
cost of your beautiful Bishop pair but
uh the question for Nakamura is whether
you just stay solid curl up into a ball
cover all your squares which he's doing
right now the black queen also very
passive
um but uh yeah what next and I think
that's the question for both players
perhaps Jessica cash just continue
advancing his pawns maybe on both flanks
on both sides of the board to try and to
create some weaknesses use maybe some
pawns as a battering ram or do both
players just sit and maintain the status
quo it's a very tense position open to
interpretation in terms of plans and uh
I'm still slightly biased because I love
playing against isolated ones but uh
yeah good cash Bishop pair nice pieces
perfectly placed pieces it's just about
uh yeah the next step
yeah and a draw is not enough for him he
has to win this game
never easy against Nakamura gotta say
okay sorry go ahead Tanya and that's the
biggest problem that you know he's done
everything right in this position all
the pieces are playing but what is the
next move how do you improve an already
very improved position here the
advantage that white does have in return
for that isolated Queen spawn is the
double Bishop bear but how good is that
with that Bishop on E3 just playing such
a big defensive role and guy as you
mentioned a draw is not enough at some
point you have to start taking risks and
here gokish is showing what his
intentions are he wants to try and set
up a battery along the b187 diagonal he
is trying to Target that eight seven
weaknesses weakness ideas of H4 Knight
G5 really hitting that soft spot on H7
come to mind as well so dukesh now
trying to build that uneven playground
in the middle game yeah and we saw it
work really effectively for Magnus
Carlson in game one of the day going for
that H7 pawn it happens in a bunch of
different openings that pattern uh is
very very important to remember if black
ever does try and blunt the effect of
this bishop uh then I think the second
plan you mentioned uh Tanya that will
come on the board very very shortly I
don't think and kakash will hesitate
from throwing this Pawn up the board you
can often just step forward with the
white king as well and slide The Rook
behind to propel it even further so
still some ideas
um I do expect Hikaru here to rotate his
Knights as he likes to say on his stream
to maybe drop this Knight back and try
and bring it to a more active Square
maybe for example then he could start
trying to trade off some pieces trade
off some Rooks black is still uh yeah
defending everything covering everything
but good cash is hinting at an attack
making hikara pause and then Bishop on
E3 isn't really doing all that much so
there's no rush for a car to take that
Bishop on the E3 Square because as soon
as you do white captures towards the
center with the pawn on F2 and once that
happened look at the quality of the
Bishops we keep talking about opposite
colored Bishops the bishop on D3 staring
all the way across towards the black
king but also can move one square
forward to put pressure on the black
queen side whereas the bishop on F6
staring into a brick wall a defended
Pawn on D4 so that I don't think would
be the best transition for Nakamura yeah
definitely something not to rush with
um the knights if we compare the pieces
that left the boat the knights uh just
one move earlier is far superior oh wow
this piece and just as we say that
commentators curse Robert wow he plays
the move we were just saying wouldn't be
a good idea and uh wow he's just happy
to uh fiancato now he's going to drop
his Bishop back and say that this is a
nice solid piece but you're right it
does stare against this kind of statue
of Pawns this Granite statue on D4
what a weird decision I've got to say
from Nakamura that must be influenced
surely by the fact he's got drawds in
this game yeah if he finds a concrete
solution he's going to go for it so it's
something you strategically don't want
to do but maybe he has it all mapped out
and who would be surprised if akaro has
seen it through to the Finish Line takes
takes takes takes takes and maybe he has
the result in the bag yeah at some point
he will try and prepare a pawn break to
open diagonals for his Bishop meanwhile
Robert again seeing deep into the future
some pressure now along this diagonal
met by a night Retreat still very tense
but uh now I think despite what the
evaluation Bar says I would slightly
prefer white chances White's position at
least easier to play perhaps in the near
future
it's a dramatic set of games right now
because we know he has to win so does
alireza farusha but I see the bar is
completely black it's actually Arjun
aragaisy winning another one
yes I'm just looking over at that board
and it looks like Ferris has taken some
huge risks in the opening it's already
moved 15 there White's King is stuck in
the center hasn't castled he's barely
developed any pieces and Eric icy
looking in top form right now and then
Magnus Carlsen he as well with uh draw
or win in game three will take the match
and the bar is saying he is winning is
that the full story yeah still some work
to do there it's level material but uh
strategic domination for Magnus Carlsen
he's fully in control of that one and he
just needs to draw remember so uh Magnus
he's gonna get that one he's gonna guide
it home and you guys remember that you
are in full control of uh decisions in
the studio if you feel we need to jump
to another game then you call out I was
going to say that before white decided
to go G4 G5 advancing the pawn in front
of his own King and this is getting
pretty hot on the board as it is uh and
gokish of course has to win on demand to
keep the match going and he's doing
everything he can to get a game I like
this move Queen to B5 it is towards the
queen side but what you want to do is
get further into your opponent's gang
account he's eyeing that D7 Square from
where he can hit the Knight on E7 he can
hit the rook and C8 the B7 Pawn is soft
uh so gokish here really creating his
chances yeah he's going for it this is
what he needs to do he needs to create
some imbalance that's already the
opposite color Bishops which doesn't
necessarily help long-term winning
chances so he has to create direct
threats I like it Tanya
um I'm not sure I go for it it's white G
Pawn push but in must win situations uh
yeah you've got to try something at
least there's an imbalance right all of
a sudden we have a situation where white
is going forward that could come at the
cost of overextension and then maybe
it's the white king that'll find itself
in trouble but if the king doesn't get
checkmated or there's no attack then I
like the mobility of White's pieces the
bishop on G7 is completely blunted by
White's pawns so some trades will be
necessary from black I think that black
does have a good position very strong
Foundation there as I've been saying all
game but I do like it from the principle
that a draw is equivalent to a loss has
to go for it yep he has to go for it to
Nakamura for the first real time in the
game he's in the tank he's trying to
figure out how to kind of neutralize the
pressure here
I would just maybe move the pawn that's
under attack I don't see too many active
choices for black right now and uh still
solid very passive especially the black
minor pieces but nakamurae I think
solidity is the key word right now for
his position I'm also looking up at the
other games a bit distracted here
because it does look like Eric ice he's
found a really powerful move in his game
he's uh gonna take that one home to
Victory soon but uh Nakamura here making
some faces not entirely happy it feels
like with his position but he knows uh
he's still done nothing wrong so he
shouldn't be punished yet by kokesh's
really ambitious play and we know we
shouldn't believe the Expressions that
Hikaru gives 100 they can be super
deceptive he needs just a draw so of
course there's a lot of margin here for
Hikaru but gokish creating his chances
I'm also keeping an eye out on the
Argent board what a mubarge and David
and we can perhaps jump to that game
because it's a big moment okay all right
we're going to do that then uh Arjun
erag icy has been crushing it today
winning the first two games against one
of uh the very best teenagers in the
world alireza farouja but the bar is
saying he is winning another one Arjun
Eric I see so we're gonna head over to
that game
is that wind getting very close for him
yeah it is because uh for I was a fruit
he needed to take a lot of risks and
that hibernation we've been talking
about where he where has he been nobody
has seen him in tournaments not even
online that can hurt you you need
practice he may be this higher rated
player he may even be the stronger
player but with the recent string of
events that our generic geissy has
played in whether it be the world rapid
and World Blitz championships then in
tons of steel he's been working on his
game honing his craft and it's showing
in this match yeah he's looking really
sharp Eric icy and it was just a one
move blunder we should mention from
farrugia in this game but he has been
taking risks and necessary risks so it's
not just about this game which he most
likely will lose but the first two games
of the day didn't look like he was
himself getting out calculated by his uh
his contemporary there both 19 years old
of course will see that Clash for years
to come and we'll see them battle it out
for 10 20 years hopefully um these two
at the top of world chest but we're
waiting for that game to appear on our
boards I don't think farrugia has moved
in the last five minutes because he's
been so stunned by a strong reply by
Eric icy and we're jumping over here we
go it's a must win situation for alireza
ferocia but you said it David he's
stunned he's stunned and look at his
pose for Russia right now he's only got
four minutes left he's been thinking for
so long Black's Queen jumping into the
center was the last move on the board
and while farouza tries to understand
how to survive here how to cope with the
ruins of his position let's go back and
show the last couple of moves because
every guy sees his last move this queen
jump was really spectacular and really
strong and it all started around here it
looked like Frugal played a very natural
move attacking the Black Knight did the
Knight have to drop back and Regice he
said no counter-attacking is another
option he attacked this white knight in
the center and uh farouza here the big
mistake was was not to start trading off
pieces instead he put his Knight on the
rim remember this was a mistake that
Serana played in the first game against
Magnus Carlson putting the Knight on the
side of the board there has to be a
concrete reason you do lose control over
the center yes the bishop is opened up
sorry to defend this Knight but you lose
control over the all-important D4 square
and queen to D4 Landing the queen
offering a trade here it's crushing
after Queen takes Queen for example
black I don't know whether you take the
queen or you flick in a night check but
uh black can choose either it feels like
and when the king moves we just
recapture the queen and two many threats
this Rook is under Fire this Pawn is
under Fire And if you take a time out to
move the Rook black does get a bunch of
Pawns on this queen side there's
actually three or four very tempting
options I'm not sure which to choose
from you could take this Pawn uh you can
take this pawn and either way you will
eventually win an end game and let's
remember that all origin era grassy
needs of the black pieces is a draw but
that would be a winning position with no
chances for white so that is likely
we're going to see something like that
we saw a queen trade on the board and I
like Knight C2 checks such a good
intermed so you don't just have to
recapture on the D4 Square maybe it's
better for your knight on B4 to land
where the queen is and we just saw
Knight C2 check played our generic guys
he's doing everything right in this
match yeah and uh just to follow this
variation Knight takes Queen is about to
happen Bishop takes bishop and it does
look like white is creating a double
attack here but black can solve this in
a bunch of ways I think you can even
capture at this point attacking the
white rook and this one does get a bit
complicated I think ferocious banking
all of his hopes on this uh you can
attack this Black Knight but in a
position such as this one defending the
Knight Bishop takes Rook look at this
the white Rook is almost powerless in
the corner look at the strength of the
two black knights combined with their
protectors the two pawns black is
actually temporarily a whole Rook down
but you will gain back at least a piece
with interest and those two knights are
worth so much more this whole match by
our turn has been his own version of
playing the Queen's Gambit his play with
the queen has been so strong in the
first round against alireza he
sacrificed an entire Queen threatening a
Checkmate in the second round we saw
this amazing Queen dance where he
eventually won a piece and queen D4 in
this game what a star move and I think
it all comes down to the geometry that
he's been seeing with the tactics and
that's not an easy thing to do when
you're playing against a player like Ali
Reza who himself is so strong when it
comes to Tactical play but archon's just
been on top of things from round one and
this one and how quick has he been he's
still got nine minutes on the clock he
sacrificed the whole Rook when he only
needs a draw he's taking huge risks but
he's seeing the board so quickly so well
right now and yeah fair play he's going
to take the win and they often say when
all you need is a draw the best thing to
do is play your normal chess play you're
not playing for a win necessarily but as
soon as you start getting overly solid
you might get a bit passive not thinking
about all your options that's no longer
chest that's just subjective thinking so
Arjun you know you couldn't ask for a
better match from him he is about to
maybe even three nil areas of faruga
what a performance from origin
especially after a tough event in tons
of steel yeah
wow and for the first time today we're
seeing Wesley so in trouble that's the
closest match so far on the scoreboard
it's 1-1 over there but mamadov one of
The Underdogs of division one right now
looks like he's winning according to the
evaluation bar we haven't followed that
one too much but we should just mention
that one is guaranteed to game four so
we will follow it a bit later he will
definitely get to see Wesley so in
action against uh marmadov game three
going on and Wesley so in trouble and so
is Ali Reza do you think alireza is uh
shocked at the level Arjun has brought
to this quarter final
I don't believe that alireza would
underestimate archon I think Arjuna has
shown phenomenal performance but
definitely going into the match many
would have picked alireza as a favorite
on paper but the match has gone on to
show that you can never underestimate
Arjun and it looks like alireza is
staring at the face of a match defeat
here and we have a winner already in the
quarter finals Magnus Carlson the world
number one
he plays a draw in game three against
Alexa Serana to take that match after
only three games that means Magnus
crawls and he stays on the winner
bracket Alexei Serrano will be knocked
down to the losers bracket to play
losers round one tomorrow Magnus Carlsen
goes through to the winners semi-finals
tomorrow
what a way to start for Magnus ah he's
looking good and it could have been 3-0
there as well Magnus took the draw from
a position of strength so uh yeah
unfortunately Serrano ran into Magnus on
a uh on a good day yeah and it's hard
for anyone even at their best to compete
but it's nice to see the one of one
looking strong yeah it could not have
gone better for Magnus and I think when
Magnus has lost the game to any player
when he plays him the next time he just
comes back with such a Vengeance yeah
and I think that's what he did today he
wanted to this was a grudge match for
Magnus and he proved his point yeah
beating someone once isn't Revenge I
think it's quote from Magnus Carlsen but
today he beat him twice and could have
won three games yeah sound defeat for
Magnus Carlson for a Lexus Runner it
doesn't get any easier that's what
happens in the Champions chess tour you
may lose a match it's double elimination
you're still in the thing but it's
likely that he's gonna face off against
Ali raise a farugia so you lose the
Magnus in an open tournament you say oh
you got to play me great you're gonna go
beat me and then go play them again now
he plays likely I'll raise a fuja yikes
tough matchups ahead yeah Magnus
carlsbon will face the winner of this
matchup in tomorrow's winners
semi-finals and that looks like it will
be Arjun all right guys see those two
played each other a bunch of times last
season on the Champions chess tour yeah
and uh often Magnus Carlsen was his
Kryptonite Eric icy uh the only one who
could stop him at times so uh this
position back to the game we do see all
of those black pawns advancing look at
the left side of the board those black
pawns marching down them and uh I think
it's inevitable one of them will
eventually cost white material or become
a new Queen and some of the viewers at
home might be wondering why is the
physician so hopeless for white it's
actually level material white has a rook
black has a knight and two pawns but
it's just the pure domination the pure
control that black has on the queen side
and once the Black Knights step out of
the way of those pawns they will
continue their inevitable advance and
meanwhile white has no counter Play No
source of activity for the remaining
pieces white tonight feeling a bit stuck
not able to jump over to defend White's
other Rook which is finely mobilized not
really going anywhere anytime soon
so with a bit of care with a bit of
control such as this last move using
that pattern that Robert used uh earlier
porn dominating that white Knight's uh
yeah this shows real uh look class from
aragaisy that's so nasty because it's
completely unnecessary it feels like he
can just push his pawns up the board but
he doesn't want to give his opponent a
sliver of hope then I don't have three
it's not going anywhere those pawns can
be pushed in a few moves and so a great
Play It's just complete dominance from
our generic Garcia I love that move F6
just making sure that Knight's got look
at this it goes to the rim it's not
going anywhere from there it's already
been there that night and it's gonna
start retreating hopping around trying
to find a better circuit I think here at
Regency will just take a timeout defend
that F6 Pawn maybe use the black king
the only piece that isn't doing too much
right now and yeah white is playing
without a couple of pieces look at that
sad white Rook completely controlled uh
by the Black Knights nowhere to go and
uh this one should be a matter of
technique as they say okay it's also 30
seconds against six minutes which
doesn't help at all I was looking at
Nora there with a coconut drink in
Panama that looked so nice jealous at
all a little bit I love it it's quite
cold in Norway as you guys now know
it's uh yeah not looking warm on the
position either look at this night
retreating struggling to find a way back
into the game
it's uh just really tough it's been a
really hot day for for Russia super hot
and he's gone 92 he wants to find a way
to the center of the board he wants to
come on to F4 D5 try and create pressure
on F6 also make sure that black spawns
on the queen side find it difficult to
advance it is winning for Arjun but he
needs to show some good technique here
he needs to find a way to push those
pawns uh it's not over till it's over
and I still think there's work to be
done here guys
sophisticated move though from Eric I
see that black Rook Landing in the
center of the board again controlling
any night jumps stopping the White
Knight jumping in and wow Eric icy blow
after blow tactically so sharp today
this move shocked me I've got to say at
first it looks like this Pawn can simply
be captured but Robert I think that's a
tactical justification yeah so that part
is captured Blackwell not recapture on
C3 the Knight will drop back to B5 you
may think oh why just give me your pawns
but there's Knight C3 check and it Forks
the king and the Rook that will scoop up
material for black so this is a
devastating tactic in arjun's favorite
he is seeing everything he's being
preemptive he's making sure the White
Knight couldn't get anywhere and now
he's assigned to pounce when the moment
is right yeah and now simply this Knight
is going to capture this Pawn it's not a
fork this time because the white Rook
moved but uh it's simply a check driving
the white king further away and these
pawns are just gonna start rolling you
can push them now you can push them
later it's uh it's gonna be inevitable
impossible to stop them now and for
Russia is now playing with seconds left
left on his clock to save this game to
save this match it's looking hopeless
for the young Frenchman
you can tell body language we sometimes
read into it sometimes we have to ignore
it but here ferocent knows that no
chance 12 seconds it's just been one of
those games one of those days
what's gone wrong for him today is it uh
his own fault so to speak or is it just
Arjun has been crushing it today
archen's been on fire he's been
tactically alert he's played great
prophylactic move being stopping his
opponent's activity he's shown great
technique even this one just just in
three moves getting a winning position
the a pawn marching down the board all
those ideas with the queen that we saw
in the earlier games just brilliant play
from start to finish he was never in the
back foot he was never worse throughout
the match so a very controlled win here
by Arjun and Robert I can see how
impressed you are on your face by these
moves from Eric icy I mean every move
has a purpose in his game right now he
just traded Rooks and you're often told
well if you have fewer Rooks where you
shouldn't trade he's saying these past
pawns are storming up the board I do not
want to give my opponent any counter
play so if the white Rook that's on C1
could jump over the Knight maybe there
would be some chances to land a few
checks and give an opportunity to stop
ponds but not from the front it seems
that if you just bring one of your
Knights either one back to the E4 square
with check then the pawns are running by
themselves it's as clear-cut as it gets
our generic guys see every move in this
game has felt extremely accurate yep you
can start advancing I think even either
of them at this point but uh yeah these
pawns aren't going to be stopped anytime
soon I'm surprised at how easy Arjun
made this one look
mm-hmm
and again logical moves will wrap up the
point like you say it's rare at the top
levels of Chess to play uh kind of such
a smooth game not allow your opponent
any counter playing six seconds for
farrugia we're expecting one of these
Knights to land with a check I'm not
sure which one's better they both look
very strong to be honest but Arjun he's
doing the right thing he's sitting on
his hands not rushing he knows this is
the critical moment he knows he's
winning just one or two accurate moves
and he'll reach that Finishing Line now
he's in calculation mode he's trying to
figure out which Knight to give the
check with and uh then which Pawn to
push so uh yeah a matter of time but I
regardless he has three minutes that
should be sufficient to calculate his
way to that win
six seconds seven or four Ali reservous
that uh is probably not enough to save
this game yeah what a move again okay
seen everything and we have to show the
justification here he's actually giving
up his night because the black pawns are
just too strong and uh if let's jump in
actually well we're going to see it on
the board this Pawn is about to promote
the white Rook has to stop it and the
other point other Pawn joins one of them
is going to become a queen and game over
three notes game over RJ and Eric icy
takes the match he goes through to the
winner his semi-finals where he will
face Magnus Carlsen also winning his
match today congratulations Magnus
thank you what has today been like a
crushing start to the Champions chess
tour season
yeah
opening the in the second game uh but
apart from that it went uh went quite
all right
and you've said before that beating
someone once isn't Revenge you did lose
to uh sarana in the The Blitz World
Championship do you feel like you got
some Revenge uh beating him in a
crushing style today
I didn't think about that uh I mean I
ended up winning the um bubblets after
all so but that's fine
and we know you're playing from Canada
actually quite early in the morning so
what has that been like to to wake up
early and start playing the Champions
chess tour
no it's not that much I mean we started
11 here and uh I haven't been here long
enough to to sort of get 1100 on off uh
European time so that's that's okay and
did you get some help from the chess Pro
the chess bras actually in preparing for
the games
uh well I mean getting things set up and
such but uh theoretical preparation was
um sorry lucky
okay got it now uh mine is we I can see
you guys working together here you do
stay on the winners bracket uh we know
you were uh well looking forward to
testing out this double elimination
format so how happy are you that you get
to stay on the winners bracket now
as I can
um so yeah tomorrow's match will uh not
be uh
easy either but um
and Magnus you're a huge sports fan what
do you think of the Jersey on the wall
behind you and the other sports
memorabilia sitting around there
[Applause]
[Music]
well I hope he does so I'll have someone
and tomorrow Magnus winners semi-finals
against Arjun aragaisy someone who
played so much last season on the
Champions chest or what's going to be
your plan against uh Arjun
uh I haven't really thought about it
um
I'll taking my match at a time and I
thought it was probably more likely that
that other reasons that but um
um yeah origin is very strong it is uh
as its best as he showed today so both
easy yeah and finally new uh format with
the clocks as well only three seconds
increments how did you like it
um it's a little bit unusual uh
especially when you get to time
scrambles and uh like I did in the
second game I was like a little bit
it was a bit unusual for me that I I
wasn't actually able to to think much I
decided to play on on anything there so
I think it will take a little bit of
time getting getting used to being more
of a sort of a
um the pure Blitz finish than
um
uh them that are used to us it's fine
right well mine is big congratulations
on a great start to the season and the
best of luck tomorrow
thank you thank you for joining us
Magnus Carlsen is one of uh several
players already ready for the Winner's
semi-finals he's gonna play Arjun Eric
icy and uh we have to get caught up on
results we do know Arjun eragaisi has
won his match against Borussia and
Hikaru Nakamura a draw and game
uh three means he is also ready for
Winner's semi-finals uh Wesley so I
didn't see Wesley so and mamadol was 601
surprisingly actually what happened
there he turned it around he was dead
lost it looked like he could barely move
a piece at some point mamidov in full
control but mamadov cashed it in at the
wrong time went into an equal end game
and got outmaneuvered Wesley was too
strong in the latter stages of that game
some Wesley saw is in the lead heading
into a game four and that one do you now
hold him as a favorite to to win that
match before it even goes to Armageddon
I don't think that anybody is envious of
the task of beating Wesley so he's one
of the most solid players on the planet
so good luck to Ralph momentov because
Wesley does not relinquish the lead very
often yeah and we have three matches
finished now Tanya I mean how surprised
are you that three players have been
actually able to crush their opposition
today I think it's a surprising result
for sure as sirana going down in just
three games Hikaru winning in three
games I think it's still believable and
then Arjun that has been the most
impressive for me in this one uh Magnus
mentioned himself that he was actually
expecting to play alireza in the next
one yeah
incredible
um David
um we didn't get to follow Wesley so's
uh third game here which was a win can
we take a look at it yep let's uh try
and jump in at The crucial moments and
uh it was around here that uh mamadolf
took control he spotted this cool tactic
I must say after the pawn to G5 he
grabbed a Pawn on B2 black is material
down he's the exchange down Rook for
Bishop but uh this bishop is now
poisoned if the White Queen takes it
then suddenly the black pawn pushes and
two threats Unstoppable threats one
making a new Queen but also Checkmate on
the G2 Square later uh he just got
outmaneuvered simply mamadov he cashed
in at the wrong moment and in this end
game night versus Bishop Wesley survived
to this point and it was eventually the
H Pawn that won him the game the black
king moved the H porn started rolling
and mamadov panicked he couldn't deal
with its advance so Wesley turning it
around but with a bit of luck on his
side
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
so much action already today three
matches finished after only three games
we're gonna take a look at everything
that has been happening but if you're
not a subscriber here's a twitch break
[Music]
I would not have bet that yuenka the
three matches would have been finished
after three games some dominant chests
that we've seen already today yeah it
has been incredible I mean what an
emotional rollercoaster I have to say
and wow
wow wow wow it's just unbelievable I
mean the way that Magnus Hikaru just
outclassed their opponents was just
something else yeah and who has
impressed you the most so far I think it
has to be Hikaru Hikaru actually just uh
completely calmly neutralized kukash
kukash really came at him quite hard and
Hikaru just made it look so easy you
know he just said okay fine you're gonna
kind of come for me and my king that's
not a problem I'm simply going to repel
it and just win material yeah win it in
the end game and then also Arjun erag
icy winning three games against the
super strong Ali reservous yeah he now
goes through to face Magnus Carlsen in
the winners semi-finals tomorrow what
kind of confidence is Arjun bringing to
that match tomorrow it feels like Arjun
is just benefiting from all the luck you
know in this match it did really
resemble that uh faruja just imploded in
those critical moments and when you have
a match that feels so easy you're just
gonna feel like your hopes are just in
the ascendant yeah wow what a day and
it's not finished you guys because one
match is yet to be decided Wesley so
against Ralph Mama Dove game four is
coming up very shortly here we go game
two you guys wow peace sacrifices
he's given up a bishop he's London
Bishop Big Choice from originator guys
tonight
the diagonal this check can be blocked
by Black's Bishop leaning back though
and it's over and here we go game three
I like this move Queen to B5 he's eyeing
that D7 Square from where he can hit the
Knight on E7 the B7 Pawn is soft uh
suggest here really creating his chances
okay he is knocked down to the losers
bracket uh for uh tomorrow Hikaru
Nakamura State
um the winner is bracket together with
Magnus Carlsen and Arjun eragaisy but
who will Hikaru face tomorrow in the
winners semifinals it's either going to
be Wesley Seoul or Ralph Mama though and
if it's going to be mamadol he will have
to win game four Wesley so it's up by
one point
and with a draw Wesley so goes through
to the Winner's bracket so what is it
about foreign
world when the guy needs just to draw
that task becomes Herculean yeah it's
just hard to imagine he's so clinical
with these things once he takes a lead
in a match he knows his task is cut he
doesn't want to create a mess on the
board he keeps everything under control
this is going to be a tough one for
Ralph yeah rank does number 102 in the
world in classical chess how big of a
surprise is it actually that Ralph
momentum is even here in the first
Division I think for those who have been
following chess for a long time they're
not surprised because Ralph mama is
insanely talented especially at quicker
time patrols he knows his theory well he
plays very quickly and he is tough as we
just saw in that game he was better
against Wesley so in game three he just
slipped at a critical moment yeah
and uh what's it going to be about for
him now he's gonna
have to win this game to take it to an
Armageddon what do you expect from the
game David it's gonna be tough it does
depend on the opening Mama Dove is very
very dangerous with the white pieces as
Robert says he knows his openings inside
out he needs to catch Wesley off guard
take him out of his comfort zone as
early as possible if Wesley gets a solid
structure a solid position maybe a
simplified position like an end game
then I think there won't be any chance
so map of he needs to keep it
complicated and go on the attack he's
done it before he did knock out an upon
the issue from the planes and let's take
a look at the the bracket three matches
in the quarterfinals have finished one
match is yet to be decided and the
winner is from the quarter finals go
through to the Winner's semi-finals
while the losers they are not knocked
out they are only knocked down to the
losers bracket to play losers round one
tomorrow we do know it's gonna be Alexa
is around against alireza Fusia in one
of those matches and it's gonna be
gukesh against either Wesley so or
mamadov and mamado he has to win now
game four it looks like right now we
will see Hikaru Nakamura against Wesley
so in the winners semi-finals tomorrow
and that's a prestigious one must be for
any American it's a rematch of the
chess.com Global Championship
semi-finals where Wesley so took down
Hikaru Nakamura to make it to the final
invention to win it over Nielsen so you
know speaking of Revenge Hikaru Nakamura
has that on his mind I mean already on
day two week can get the match up Wesley
so against the car Nakamura that would
be incredible yeah and they've got so
much respect for each other both of
course of course in the world's Elite
for many many years now they've played
each other in the global Chess
Championship they played each other in
one of the Grand Prix finals last year
Fida Grand Prix and uh yeah that one is
too tough to call both of them
incredibly hard to beat and both of them
super fast so uh that would be exciting
but first Wesley needs to overcome Ralph
mamadov that is exactly what he needs to
do a draw in this game with the black
pieces means so Wesley so stays on the
Winner's bracket it's must win for Ralph
mama dog but he does have the white
pieces
and here we go and uh before we can
predict the opening before Kai can get
it right again it's one E4 and Wesley
he's not going to back down from his
normal repertoire his standards uh
standard repertoire his default setting
is Rock Solid anyway and I expect to see
maybe the Berlin defense if given the
opportunity one of the hardest nuts to
crack in uh terms of chess openings what
will namadov go for now it's strange to
pause on move three I've got to say uh
either you bring your Bishop out which
is what nearly all top players do
nowadays or you have maybe a sideline up
your sleeve but uh you've got to
surprise Wesley you've got to do it now
and there are some adventurous lines in
the scotch the problem is Wesley so
plays this Scotch opening from the white
side so you're not going to catch him
off guard there we get the Italian a
slower start but maybe there will be
some tricks up rough moment of sleeve
yeah at least with the Italian game we
do often see all of the pieces still on
the border move 15 move 20 and even
beyond that so uh going for maximum
tension here from amidov and it is one
of the main lines of the Italian game it
will just slow down I expect go to a
maneuvering phase Tanya who do you think
that's this is going to favor I
completely understand the decision to go
for the Italian the Spanish would be a
bad idea because it would allow the
Berlin as you mentioned Scotch not a
great opening against Wesley with the
Italian the reason that Ralph is taking
time in the opening is that you have to
kind of decide your own setup how you
want to place your pieces it's all about
the little pawn moves do you commit C3
do you go shot Castle do you first bring
out your knight to D2 what do you do
with the a pawn and all that will
determine the kind of middle game that
Ralph will get all he wants to do is to
make sure that he has flexibility that
is why he's chosen to move C3 always
eyeing that Center break on D4 he wants
to First of course finish his
development and I'm expecting a
developing move right now bringing out
the night or going short Castle I like
this approach by Ralph in a
win-on-demand situation yep the Italian
game it wasn't in fashion up until maybe
the mid 2010s and suddenly everyone was
playing it suddenly everyone was beating
me with it and uh yeah it's uh it tends
to be a good opening in these must-win
types of situations however of course
Wesley so vastly experienced both uh
with white and with black in this
opening and mamadov doesn't look like
he's enjoying it on the camera I've got
to say doesn't look too optimistic about
his chances he still played very logical
moves black now castling white is super
flexible you can Castle yourself you can
delay that if you want to maybe maneuver
your pieces a bit further but either way
he's got to believe in his chances uh in
this game otherwise he won't get it
looking one of the most unpleasant
things in the Chess World is to play for
a win against an opponent like Wesley
saw he's just so hard to beat so well
prepared give him one opportunity he
takes it and doesn't give you a chance
he keeps everything under control and I
like that white hasn't committed a short
Castle move so now Ralph is really
thinking does he want to try to create
something on the king side now that
black has gone a shot Castle himself or
will he play a slower Italian with the
ideas the Thematic ideas of transferring
the Knight to the king side to G3 yeah
and that's one idea there's a bunch of
options you can go for while Ralph has
another slightly confusing long think
here this is the one that you're
recommending here Tanya it can happen
now or on the next moves for example if
you wait you can wait maybe by dropping
your Bishop back or by pushing a pawn
you could also try and tempt black to
play a useful looking move such as this
one just stopping any later Bishop pin
along this diagonal but now suddenly
white could use this Pawn as a hook and
uh perhaps try to start attacking and
look at what Ralph has done he's hoping
for a slip like this from Wesley of
course it won't happen Wesley's too
experienced he knows all of the ins and
outs of all of these plans for both
sides but Ralph drops his Bishop back
saying okay you commit first you show me
your hand you show me your plan and then
I'll decide where to put my pieces if
you push this Pawn forward I might well
start blasting open the king side and
try to castle with my king on the
opposite flank later if you don't commit
to that move at least I'll know what
setup you're going for what you intend
to do so interesting kind of Mind Games
here and those are the questions that
Ralph especially is asking himself right
now and Wesley is deliberating here
because he has many attractive moves he
can just bring his light Square Bishop
out to E6 offer a trade pieces he he
does just that as soon as I mention he
could have first lit his Rook over to
protect that square but he decides let's
go for the trade if white has just spent
a turn going Bishop back to B3 now
Bishop takes E6 it seems like you're a
Tempo down from the white side so
there's no fear uh for black opening up
that file instead Ralph castles but I
just don't feel this is the type of
position he won he's in must win
territory and I truly believe that
Wesley so may be the single worst
opponent to play when you need to win
Magnus Carlson needed to beat him in
classical chess in Vikings a he hit mags
of the white pieces couldn't do it
Wesley was super solid so I just think
that Wesley he's too precise and he does
not play with any risk yeah and this
position looks like a dream for black if
we talk about openings and their
outcomes uh now you can just drop your
Bishop back this bishop is attacked and
at some point later you can aim to break
forward in the center it feels like
black is equalized effortlessly light
squared Bishops have left the board and
every peace trade will guide Wesley
towards safety at least for black and uh
yeah I think it's not unfortunately been
the most successful of Italian games for
Ralph but can he keep the tension can he
keep the winning chances I don't think I
want to face Wesley in a must win
situation I definitely don't want to
face him in this position either because
it looks right up his alley it looks uh
like he's well in his comfort zone and
once that Bishop Falls black back Wesley
is already threatening to advance the a
pawn to attack the White Knight on B3 so
white will again have to spend another
Temple stopping that idea because if
black is able to advance further on the
queen side then you get more space with
the pawn jumping forward so once I think
Bishop to B6 happens white will have to
make the move A4 giving black the
opportunity to make that Central break
that we've been talking about with D5
yeah and it's surprising neither side
took time out to go for a ride of those
plans instead Wesley just takes a time
now to cover this Square for uh for the
white Bishop you don't allow any pin you
don't allow any uncomfortable tension
there of course white can't Propel his
pawns forward and go uh to try and open
lines against this hook because White's
King has finally committed to the king
side and he's arguing that a knight
takes Bishop type of moved will actually
favor Black because suddenly a semi-open
file a backward Pawn to Target if the
black Brooks can line up against it it
might well just drop off the board later
interesting decision and uh just Safety
First approach again from Wesley so
classy just preventing any Glimpse any
hint of activity for White's Bishop
and we see the pieces swapped off though
I think that gives at least Ralphs
something to consider that in the long
term he has the bishop against a knight
uh the pawn and C5 not really a weakness
I actually consider it a strength
because white will never be able to push
that D3 Pawn up to D4 so what black will
likely do is just double or triple along
the D file bring the Rooks to the party
and start putting pressure on that
square so I don't think that immediately
white has any progress at least not easy
to make but down the road if white also
doubles the Rooks behind that pawn maybe
there are some eventual breaks
maneuvering of the pieces that can give
Ralph some hope so it's not an advantage
certainly not but at least something to
hope for yeah it's some imbalance and
that's the most you can hope for when
you're trying to win a game you just uh
change the type of pieces you have
change the pawn structure slightly and
hope that long term that pays off but uh
yeah for now it's very much a slow
maneuvering game while these players try
to figure out their strategies and first
of all Wesley has to defend that pawn on
C5 probably with a pawn maybe with this
queen
he's just breaking open the center
targeting that D3 pawn and says come and
take my C4 Pawn not only do you double
up your own pawns but watch out for that
pawn in the center notice how the E4
Pawn gets weak and black will be able to
snap that up with his own Knight I love
this move it solves the problem of
having the double pawns for black and
now the ball's in White's coat and not
pleasant choices to be made here for
white yeah it's a dilemma already for
Ralph uh either you capture this Pawn as
we're pointing out there and black now
has a four versus three majority on the
king side in terms of Pawns meanwhile
White's double pawns don't make a great
impression here or this sad alternative
would be
um well what is the alternative it's
hard to come up with a move maybe to
drop the Knight back allowing a
symmetrical Pawn structure you have an
issue of this Pawn I guess you could
defend it and then pick up this Pawn
next for black uh for white but very
maximum here you just get symmetrical
Pawn structure and a dead quality and
that's being optimistic that's what
happens when you make one careless move
against a superstar like Wesley so the
move Bishop E3 such a natural developing
move attacking the pawn that was on C5
it seems at first he should have brought
his Queen up to the E2 square that way
C4 is in the threat then developed his
Bishop then connected his Rooks and La
that would have given him much more to
play for but look at Wesley he does not
even pause for a second he swaps the
Queens off and all he needs is the draw
he might even be the side for choice in
this end game with the healthier Pawn
structure it's going to be a four on
three majority uh and the King side if
it cut the board in half and for white
that four on three majority you got
double pawns you're not going to be able
to create a pass Pawn this is just great
for Wesley so you know I just love how
he instantly Hoovers off the Queens I
think most of us would be reluctant to
give away and Seed the D file but he
doesn't care he knows that the root can
infiltrate it's just one move and uh
soon The Rook will be evicted from the
black half just really calm eliminating
all the pieces eliminating all the
danger just classic Wesley so this is
amazing stuff I mean this queen shred he
doesn't want to give any chance to his
opponent the reason he decided to take
on D1 and then on e4 is that if you
capture the pawn on e4 if you just back
up one move and take on e4 instead it
allows the sliver of Hope for white with
the move Queen D5 centralizing the queen
putting pressure on black and if you
take that Queen well it's a pawn
structure that you will suffer in the
end game but Wesley doesn't want to go
through any of that trades the Queens
just again very clinical play when he
needs a draw yeah very clinical play and
we see here Ralph lamidov just Shuffle
his Rook to the side it's looking very
very good uh very solid for Wesley and a
bunch of moves here you can kind of
protect your Pawn your knight indirectly
you can just jump back with the Knight
if you're scared of it being attacked in
the next few moves you could even if
you're feeling ambitious push this Pawn
forward I'm not sure how much risk where
to leave so will take now but yeah it
does feel like he's a big favorite to
make the draw he needs and I do see some
questions in the awesome twitch chat if
you are watching on the chess.com
channel on Twitch some people asking if
this is the last game of today and it is
if Wesley so wins this game or let's say
draw then this is actually the last game
of today but the action continues
tomorrow with winners semi-finals and
losers round one and Ralph momodov he
did lose game three to Wesley so and uh
he was very upset afterwards
look at that
and this was his chance this game was
his chance yeah because he had winning
chances as well in this game
yeah it's more than just winning chances
it's uh he knows he had it in the bag
and it's so hard to recover it's not
just affecting that one game that he
lost it's affecting this game and you
can see on his body language he's not
feeling uh too happy with himself
because if he were able to at least draw
in game three he would have the white
pieces here in game four that would send
it potential to Armageddon and people
can't forget that in the chess.com
Global Championship Neil sarin made to
the final when he lost and became
runner-up to Wesley so but he almost
lost in round one to Ralph momento this
is not someone who just appeared on the
scene this is somebody who's been around
the block he's wrecking Ralph and he
knows that if he's playing his best
chess he can take down Wesley so in a
match so that is why he was so upset he
had his chance he was out playing Wesley
in fact throughout the match I don't
think he's really been worse except for
that one end game that David was
highlighting for the H Pawn started to
run yeah
very close and it's always more
heartbreaking when you know you are on
the brink of Victory if you get
outclassed if you get outplayed then you
could have just accept it uh and that
can happen against someone as strong
especially so but he's had his
opportunity massive opportunity and now
he's got to do it all over again and uh
okay he's played some decent moves I
quite like what white has done in terms
of Pawn structure on the king side he's
pushed his Jeep on forward normally a
dark Square Bishop is well complimented
by uh pawns on light squares but still
an uphill struggle to create weaknesses
Flex very solid and oh a trade of Rooks
interesting decision giving away the D
file this time and it's all to push his
Pawn forward talks about wrecking Ralph
he's trying to wreck the pawn structure
sorry getting the feeling that Ralph is
over pushing right now he almost feels
like he's going a little bit on tilt
here and not taking that much time
making all these very strong rash
decisions of pushing the pawn trading
the Rooks on the D file uh I think when
we saw him that upset on the screen it's
also because for the players who are
making that debut in the Champions
Chester it's really an opportunity that
they've never had before and they've
been able to do that this time because
of the new format which allows Grand
Masters to qualify and play in the tour
so it definitely means a lot and to have
that winning opportunity against the
player like Wesley it can be really
frustrating because you know if you have
to win on demand against him just how
hard it will be right now we're seeing
by Ralph these moves advancing the pawn
G4 G5 to me it seems more on tilt and
more rash than an actual should try for
a win yeah it feels like minimum reward
but quite a lot of risk involved but
then again a draw is the same as a loss
for him so he's just trying to confuse
Wesley create some chances you can't
just sit there and beat Wesley with a
very stable Pawn structure uh instead
he's at least trying to change again the
Dynamics of the position imbalance
things slightly and maybe we can jump in
because Wesley has paused I thought his
move was automatic I wouldn't actually
consider anything else here for black
other than capturing this g-pawn this
straggler in the black camp but what
else could he be thinking about where
Ralph's idea we should mention after 0.6
Pawn is to recapture with the bishop and
again a bit of an annoying pin but
mostly uh it's all about pressure on
this E5 pawn and uh Wesley what else
could he be considering here why has he
stopped for the last couple of minutes I
think it's exactly that he is trying to
calculate a little bit ahead to see how
he wants to actually respond to that
attack on the E5 Pawn it's not very
pleasant to actually sidestep with your
Rook to the closed file the close the
file to defend your own pawn and then
allow White's Rook to step forward so
not wanting that he decides to take
another decision uh David he doesn't
want to allow white to put pressure on
the E file he falls back with the Knight
on H7 that's slightly surprising to me
I'm trying to figure out what's the idea
is this not a pawn Sacrifice by Wesley
so after Pawn takes Pawn this pawns
defended by his Bishop he answers your
question we're all looking confused okay
Robert I think I understand it so even
though objectively it seems it was a
mistake if we just go back if he had
indeed captured on G5 and that Rook E8
was the follow-up after Bishop takes
pawn and if Bishop takes F6 G takes F6
we see the evaluation bar if you've got
this position the board says Ah it's
level not a big deal but there is this
out side pass Pawn because each one that
black needs to stop so in certain end
games with pieces getting traded white
may just be winning so Wesley is likely
relying on and what he did in the game
is he sacrificed the pawn but said that
pawn I'm likely going to be able to
Corral it and win it later so let me
just keep the remaining punch structure
healthy for black and then proceed from
there I think that it was a mistake the
other line did not look particularly
scary but at least I understand what
Wesley was thinking and doing this and
he may just try to create a fortress
push his Pawn up to F6 bring his King
out to F7 and maybe when the time is
right he can start pushing his pawns on
the king side and say that white is
stuck in his tracks no more progress to
be had
something like this and as you say
Robert maybe bring the Knight around
eventually this Pawn you can now go for
it with your king with your Rook maybe
um it's not going to get anywhere for
now and black is still super solid but
being a pawn down you want to avoid it
if you can in an end game uh very
surprising we said that Wesley he's so
solid but uh yeah here he's making a bit
of a risky decision and the evaluation
bar does react I'm not sure whether it's
just because white is a pawn up so the
evaluation Bar says okay slightly better
for white right now but wow what a move
by Ralph mamidov he's going for it on
the other flank as well this could be
potentially very strong and a bit of a
shock to Wesley he's played B4 and this
Pawn is covered twice this Square by
Black's pieces for example after a
recapture black and even take with his
Knight but suddenly uh White has very
aggressive moves first thing Knight
takes Pawn is an idea The Rook could
also swing across I'm not sure which one
is stronger out of those two but uh
Ralph he's trying to give up the pawn to
get a pawn back and the more lines that
become open the more that will favor
whites ship and Rook so Wesley wants
none of that he just simply sets up that
solid porn wall in the center and Ralph
I think he's going to start stepping
forward why not this is where he has the
majority four versus three it's gonna be
hard to create passport here but at
least he's kicking away the black pieces
interesting stuff this is fantastic play
by Ralph to try to create his chances
and after F6 he has the option to
actually slide with his Rook already to
the B file now that the if bond is
supported you defund your own pawn and
you want to try to push your pawns and
gain space on the Queen's side and with
that H Pawn still alive it looks like
all the risk that he was going for has
paid off yeah I like it I'm starting to
like it a lot for white this Pawn does
tie down a whole night after all and uh
okay he's just solidified his Pawn
structure with his own Pawn looks like a
bit of a kind of hesitant move a bit of
an indecisive move but at least he has
enough imbalance now to have a chance of
winning this game what do you think get
right now Robert chances we will see our
Armageddon on this very first day of the
Champions chess tour 2023. pretty good
chances I think that this decision was
one that Wesley might kick himself for I
understand it I can get behind it to
some extent because he thinks he has a
fortress an impenetrable setup he may be
down one Pawn but good luck to getting
to any of the others but as we've been
highlighting there are issues on the
queen side white does have an extra Pawn
on that side of the board and black
isn't just going to win this Pawn on H6
that's a passer that's going to remain
at the very least tied down some of
Black's forces to it so I do think that
this game will go on for quite a while
and that's good news for Ralph and his
winning chances yeah it's almost as if
Wesley was in a must win situation
taking that decision giving up a pawn
very very strange stuff and okay he's
pushed his Pawn to G5 so cutting the
coordination between White's bishop and
that pass Pawn on H6 black has a clear
plan now he's simply going to advance
the black king towards that loan uh Pawn
on H6 but
again white has two moves white has at
least two moves maybe while that plan
happens how can he best take advantage
of the time that Wesley's given him I'm
still looking for ways to push on the
queen side it looked like Ralph was
reluctant to do that in the last few
moves White's Knight Waits Bishop a bit
stuck they need to improve
um Tanya do you see any plans here for
white I'm trying to work out if there's
any way forward any concrete uh moves
here one thing's for sure right you've
got to try and keep that eight six Pawn
alive for as long as you can and the one
thing that white needs to do to make
that happen is to push the other age
Pawn once you go H4 you break this G5
bond which is stopping the connection
between the bishop on E3 and the pawn on
86 so it can really stay on the board
for a long time distracting black spaces
and once that happens you can try to
expand on the queen side I like the idea
and I like the move B5 kicking that
black knight away and then advancing the
C Pawn further down the board creating a
second weakness on the queen side yeah
Second Avenue for attack potentially I'm
also looking at White's Knight in this
variation you mentioned after it pushes
forward the black pawn will attack it
anyway so I'm not sure whether we flick
in this move and then perhaps go here to
attack this black pawn or perhaps go
towards the center but uh ideally we
want to land the night in this on this
beautiful post on e4 but it might get
stopped by Black's Pawn advance so I'm
wondering do you go for it now in the
current position here at least it feels
looser for black to push this Pawn
forward to prevent White's night getting
in uh it could start hopping around some
really uh sweet juicy squares and he
does go for this very natural Move That
Knight was not doing too much and uh
okay he first flicks in H4 and G4 so he
has opened up once again the protection
of this Pawn
interesting stuff I'm stunned to like
his chances a lot
it's getting double edged but that's
what you need if you're playing for a
win all of a sudden black is pushing
those pawns forward uh the F Pawn may go
up the board as well and don't be
surprised if black starts creating
threats that Rook can slam down the D3
square at some moment so white needs to
act uh without caution I mean you need
to play quickly because if you just
start making slow moves like bring your
king to the side to F1 things of that
nature it seems like black will be the
first to attack the pawn H6 protected
it's safe for now but it's not doing
anything it's blockaded so I think that
black is ready to strike yeah black is
ready to strike and uh Wesley I think
both sides just need to play quickly now
they both need to throw caution to the
wind and just go for it Wesley can't
just think of locking this down with a
fortress that doesn't exist anymore long
term white is still doing extremely well
so uh he needs to push pawns maybe land
that black rook in the heart of White's
camp and uh Ralph there shaking his head
kind of looking up it's as if he's still
dwelling in the past he's still
remembering that missed opportunity in
game three he needs to focus now because
he's played very well he's created
chances out of nothing seemingly and
it's actually Wesley who needs to come
up with answers in this uh in this exact
moment
and that's one of the hardest things to
do as a chess player is to forget what
has just happened especially when you
know that you had a big opportunity and
you let that slip to forget that to
leave that behind and focus on what's in
front of you is definitely a big
Challenge and in this format it doesn't
get any easier so we see a decision to
trade on before the big question to my
mind here is uh Robert David what is
White's idea if black does go F5 I want
to trap that Bishop on E3 I want to go
F4 your knight on D2 is hanging how are
you responding to F5 yeah Wesley hasn't
gone for it yet he's holding back it
feels as if he's still trying to play
with the brake on uh but you're right
Tanya this is uh on tap anytime you want
it for example if white does mess around
with seemingly kind of useful move but
not doing too much then this is
definitely going to be in one idea for
black uh the Knight suddenly has to move
just to create some squares for the
bishop perhaps to retreat but this is
really kind of uh not what you want to
see you don't want to start pushing
pieces back so instead Ralph continues
with the plan he initial a couple of
minutes ago Landing his Knights on e4
and Wesley immediately lands his own
Knight on this very nice Square hinting
at simply grabbing pawns back we see the
issue with what Ralph did he brought
Knight to D2 he centralized his Knight
how could you possibly complain about
that decision but when black played the
move Pawn G5 to G4 uh David Your
Instinct I think was correct to drop the
Knight towards the rim to attack that
pawn and induce the pawn up to F5
because if that black pawn were already
in F5 the Knight couldn't hop there
what's that Knight doing attacking not
just the bishop on E3 but the pawn on H4
and the pawn on H6 all at the same time
black can bring the king up to F7 as
well The Rook can still go up to D3
white is up a pawn but it's doubled
pawns on the C file not making progress
just yet I think Wesley makes it look
easy sometimes he made probably an
objective mistake by giving up a pawn
but practically speaking it looked like
he's had no issues since then yeah if we
think about simple positions or end
games or certain positions where there
are simple plans Wesley I think he's
number one in the world uh maybe with
Magnus Carlson up there too it's just he
makes it look so straightforward as if
you know how do did you not see this
earlier how did you not understand this
plan he just uh he's so consistent once
he finds an idea and he's going for it
now it's very hard to hold everything
together for white I don't see how white
is actually hold on to that extra Pawn
you're threatening to take on H4 you're
threatening to land that Knight on F3
with a devastating check uh the only way
that I can see white creating any play
is to take advantage of the open a file
shift that Rook from the center now all
the way across the board go to A1 start
targeting the seventh rank the pawns on
the seventh rank the H4 Pawn is dead and
gone yeah you just have to say bye bye
I'm gonna give you a pawn back and you
have to activate those white pieces but
two minutes now for Ralph five for
Wesley it's not looking uh promising in
terms of a fight back anymore just one
or two slips and that's all Wesley needs
oh this is uh looking tough I don't envy
him in this position and the white king
is actually wide open there are plenty
of checkmating attacks if we go for uh
Tanya's line if we can just show a few
moves that that would lead to a force
checkmating sequence let's say The Rook
slides to A1 the Black Knight takes on
H4 The Rook goes up to A7 great you're
throwing those pawns but in Comes The
Rook to D1 with check the King has only
one safe Square on H2 because the Knight
covers G2 the Knight hops into F3 would
check and no matter where the King goes
up to G3 or over to G2 Rook G1 is check
and made so remember this configuration
with a knight on F3 defended by a pawn
once The Rook slides in it is going to
be a mate against the white king so I
think that Wesley has this all under
control yeah it's looking like Black's
pieces they're just coordinating so well
right now it looks odd in a way because
this Knight is paralyzed it's stuck just
blockading a pawn but uh the rest of
Black's pieces the rest of the structure
is uh perfect and wow we're all reacting
here in the studio because Ralph was
maybe out of desperation sacrifice to
peace he's given up his night just for a
couple of Pawns and wow okay he's
created a pin this surely can't work
that's a one more thing you just
sidestep it defend your night on F6 go
Rook to f8 and how does white continue
there I guess there's another Pawn up
for grabs this Pawn can also be captured
he's just gambling here Ralph he knows
he's in a must win situation and he's
saying okay I don't care about pieces
but uh I guess this Pawn will be taken
and the Black Knight steps back
defending this uh defending its fellow
here it's hard to believe I've got to
say that white has enough for the piece
but you do have three pawns even if they
are ugly double pawns and it gives you
chances because a lot of the other
variations you may not lose the game but
you're certainly not going to win this
gives Wesley some room to go wrong and
that's all you can ask for at this stage
of the game so objectively to the
evaluation bar saying come on what is
that but from Ralph momentum a draw
equals a loss you might as well go down
swinging yeah I've got to say the more I
look at it the more I like it he's
definitely Taking Chances but that's the
only way you win games at the top level
you have to take big risks and from a
human point of view Wesley will no
longer feel in control he's suddenly on
the defensive and he has to hold things
together he goes for tania's move
defending his Knight here but now
another Pawn will disappear there we go
another Pawn drops and suddenly black
still on the back foot
I still believe Wesley's defensive
resources are more than sufficient here
but uh yeah from a human point of view a
good practical decision from Ralph if
they switched the times then Ralph would
have a legitimate chance but
unfortunately for him it is Wesley up
three minutes on the clock so worst
position time management not there for
you so Wesley does have things under
control he is so strong in positions
just like this yeah and uh at least his
job is easier now Wesley just pure
defense he's done the hard work he's
material up with this Black Knight extra
Black Knight but Ralph he's going for
all the pawns this is very greedy I've
got to say but will the great pay off uh
Black's Knights once they coordinate
will actually form quite a devastating
attacking threat against the white king
and actually similar patterns to the one
Robert pointed out earlier might occur
on the board later if white gets greedy
and goes with his Rook to capture that
black g-pawn uh in the near future first
Ralph just advancing and trying to
improve to the maximum and then he'll go
Pawn hunting they are fighting to uh
save a spot on the winners bracket to
face Hikaru Nakamura in the winner is
semi-finals tomorrow the loser will be
knocked down two of the losers bracket
in this double elimination format to
face gukash in the loser is round one
tomorrow now you guys at home are
fighting to win an air things device
keep sharing your selfies on Twitter
using the hashtag chess Champs
preferably in landscape mode we want to
know where in the world you are
following the action where you are
watching the chess who you're watching
it with and the most creative selfie
will get a signed air things device
Magnus Carlsen has signed some of these
devices and we will send one of them
home to a lucky viewer and meanwhile the
pride and joy of White's position has
disappeared that past H Pawn the front
one the H6 Pawn it's disappeared not
only that but another set of pieces have
been traded off so it is currently black
having a night White having three Pawns
in return material equality
the quality uh is uh not there
unfortunately that black knight once it
enters the game
should decide things in Black's favor
and it's happening on the next move you
can already start bringing up the Knight
to E5 and putting pressure on the F2
weakness by jumping onto D3 things are
looking super Bleak and that sacrifice
that we saw the Practical chance that we
saw by Ralph it was a measure of
desperate desperate times called for
desperate measures and everything I
think uh the knight jump by Wesley to F5
is really what's sealed uh the deal in
this game yeah he's uh made some very
impressive night jumps uh in this one
Wesley and I'm surprised he's hesitating
I've got to say maybe he's just looking
for the most clinical way to kill off
this game he could just jump in and
improve his Knights even further he can
maybe just improve the black Rook but no
he goes for that white H porn with his
King he's already won one Pawn with this
King why not go for a second H Pawn and
uh yeah it's holding things together now
for Ralph maybe some drawing chances to
eliminate those two remaining black
pawns if you get rid of those uh rook
and Knight versus Rook is a technically
drawn end game but at the moment it
feels like a distant dream and even a
draw remember not enough for him to stay
in this match and Wesley locks things
down on the queen side locks things down
and I feel like his camera is locked
down Wesley hasn't moved since the start
of the game
he does that he puts his hand over his
head he wants to focus on nothing but
the board in front of him and right now
he's showing why in the end game you can
use your King as a weapon it doesn't
just need to be defended that King is
out in the open but it's going after
White's vulnerable Pawn so great
performance by Wesley so in this game uh
he'd sacrificed the pawn it looked a
little shaky but since then it has been
nothing short of a master class and the
advantage is only growing yeah
now he could just pick up a pawn with
his King right now I don't think there's
any mating ideas that black king is safe
enough I was going to say I saw Wesley
blink so he's not just Frozen there with
the camera he finally does change his
posture but it's too late for Ralph
mamidov he's just trying to swap off all
the pawns now Ralph and get a draw to
salvage some pride but Wesley is going
to take this match and continue in the
winners bracket that last black pawn if
it survives should ensure a win but uh
very minimum here as Wellesley you could
just trade off everything remaining on
the board
and there we go he does want to end on a
high he does defend that black pawn
Black's King still caged but the Black
Knight now will relocate and that will
be the beginning of the end
and for Wesley he doesn't want to
necessarily win this game sometimes you
look at a position you look at the
evaluation bar how could Wesley make a
choice completely winning if he sees a
three-time repetition he's taking it
because all he wants is to make it
through to the Winner's semifinals he
wants to play Hikaru Nakamura tomorrow
so the win in this game it doesn't mean
anything to him let's just secure the
match yeah we saw that from Carlson and
Nakamura that professional approach both
of them took draws in positions of
strength in the third games of uh their
match just to secure match Victory it's
all about the next round the end goal is
to win the ethics Masters the end goal
is not necessarily to win this game so I
think you're right Robert I've seen
Wesley do it plenty of times before
take the safe approach and meanwhile the
black Rook
starting to get to a normal active
Square eventually I don't really see any
hope here for white to win this game
he's advancing with his King maybe
hinting at some Checkmate attacks
against the black king you've got to be
slightly careful if the white Rook steps
up there's a mate in one threat if it
slides across to H7 the black king is
trapped but you do have a move a
valuable move for Wesley to break this
construction I'm expecting the Black
Knight to jump back check hit the white
king force it away and no more cage for
the black king actually even after the
check once the white Kings does step
forward white is still threatening or
made on its seven so what black wants to
do with this check is give a check on D4
as well and keep checking that white
king yeah there's always a glimmer of
hope uh as long as you've got a
Checkmate threat on the board so we did
see a couple of tracks the Black Knight
wait that is not legal don't fall into
it now it's still there the threat of
course Wesley has spotted it and the
repetition it begins
and uh I think Ralph can only avoid the
draw now if he goes forward with the
white king but that would also be
playing for a loss he knows his chances
of uh progressing in this match are gone
but now it's Wesley who doesn't go for
the draw surprise I was about to say you
predicted the future but no he's playing
on I'm shocked because he doesn't need
to win this game he could have just
ended with the repetition it said he
brings his King back and maybe he's
enjoying the fact that he is a better
position because in the three prior
games it was really deadlocked in fact
in game three Ralph mametov had the
advantage so for Wesley perhaps it's a
moment to enjoy before he goes and plays
akara Nakamura tomorrow
yep and uh often on the first day of
tournaments it's nice to play a long day
I know it's tiring but you feel fully
warmed up you feel kind of back in the
zone so uh Wesley's kind of pushing this
the long game here I feel will benefit
him in days to come and uh meanwhile
Ralph just keeping the pressure on
keeping an eye on that black C6 Pawn not
gonna help but uh he's trying
he's down to 24 seconds is he regretting
not just repeating the moves and
wrapping up the match just get out of
here take the draw and move on
um yeah it's surprising what's Wesley
thinking about 15 seconds and only three
seconds increment remember 10 seconds
okay he made the move there he does give
another check he's still on tap that
type of repetition if you kind of uh
perpetually check that white king I
think we're gonna see it now David I
think the Knight will jump back to D4
we'll jump back to E6 if required and uh
surely a draw but no he plays for the
win again I came going Wednesday so what
is he doing this is Wesley 2.0 but it
just feels so unnecessary right now it
feels like you're playing for a loss if
anything and remember if he loses we
will see Armageddon is there a chance
mama will win this game still Wesley
still has to go completely crazy for
that to happen but he's made some
strange decisions and okay he's getting
checked back to the edge with his King
the white Pawn is advancing he's down to
13 seconds when he had the jaw in his
hands yeah now you have to calculate
like White's Rook could slide across and
offer a trade and I think it's fine for
black there but some risk involved and
okay Ralph is gone for this suddenly
white has two past pawns Rooks are off
the board that black knight is a great
blockader under control still for black
should be a draw once that black uh Pawn
drops off the board but uh Wesley he
played it a bit close to the line there
he took some risks unnecessary once and
surprising from Wesley so because he
doesn't do that in events where he
really needs to win and so when he
doesn't need to win he's suddenly
deciding to take that risk but you might
be right David it's day one he's just
saying let me get into tournament shape
I'm gonna win this match and I have an
objectively better position he's about
to be a draw the Knight checks the king
it's going to win this Pawn on D7 and
then the last Pawn is stop we see Knight
in King versus King you cannot win that
it is a draw and that means Wesley so
moves on wow it is over after four games
Wesley so wins this matchup and the
quarterfinals he stays on the winner
bracket to face Hikaru Nakamura tomorrow
in the winner is semi-finals Ralph
momondov is knocked down to the losers
bracket and will play go cash tomorrow
and the losers round one feels so harsh
to say loser it's about these fantastic
players but that's double elimination
winners back then losers bracket yeah
you can call it the lower bracket it
makes you feel better but no matter what
you lost today's match you only have one
match to spare if you lose again you are
out of this tournament so tomorrow's a
new day and hopefully a new result for
those who lost in today's matches yeah
and Wesley so he is one of the favorites
in the tournament he finishes off with a
draw in this game winning one game today
to win the match and this game was there
any drama happening David there was and
Ralph did try his best full credit to
him for Taking Chances and at least
attempting something attempting to throw
Wesley off balance and I want to
compliment uh Ralph's Choice here by
giving up a piece this is very difficult
for any human player to give up material
but you have to take your chances you
have to create threats and give your
opponent a chance to go wrong it had
already gone a bit wrong for Wesley so
but he'd recovered he'd stabilized and
we were pointing out already some nice
variations for black including going for
the white king some potential mating
attacks Ralph tried to change the
momentum another important factor when
you're trying to win games by
sacrificing a piece but unfortunately it
didn't work and he created a pin double
threat here a pin along this diagonal
and this black Pawn on E5 about to drop
off but Wesley now
as usual uh he defended everything he
held everything together and uh Rook
takes Pawn he just dropped his Knight
Back The Rook defends the Knight the
Knight defense every square that white
Rook wants to use and just two moves
later we saw at the beginning of the end
black was able to Hoover up this pawn
and slowly but surely guide the game
towards safety
he's going for it on the other flank as
well this could be potentially very
strong and a bit of a shock to Wesley
Ralph is maybe out of desperation
sacrificed a piece this surely can't
work
wow uh all the games day one in
Champions Chester 2023 have finished how
is Summit of Tanya
I mean for me the star of the day was
definitely Arjun defeating alireza in
those three games and we saw so much
drama and dominating play for the three
matches Ralph was the big surprise he
really had an upper hand and I think
that was slightly heartbreaking for him
and then of course Wesley doing Wesley
things keeping everything under control
it was truly a day filled with Fighting
Chess and drama what will be the
reactions in India to Arjun aragaisy
it's huge performance today everyone's
going to be super excited he also plays
Magnus tomorrow and that is something we
all really look forward to arjun's had
tough results against him but over time
he sort of realized that he needs to
stop fearing Magnus so much and he has
had better performances ever since then
so a big match coming up I think tonight
is about celebrating for India seeing
Arjun go through and of course gokish
gets Another Second Chance in the losers
bracket yep that's the great thing about
double elimination everyone gets a
second chance let's take a look at the
results from the quarterfinals today
Magnus Carlson a dominant win against
Alexa Serrano winning two games were you
impressed with Magnus today Robert it
was Flawless it felt like Magnus was at
what star's throat from the beginning he
never gave him a chance so impressive
display from the world champion and then
Hikaru Nakamura also winning two games
against gukesh what can you say about
the hikaru's play today David it was uh
classic Hikaru smooth polished very
classy and uh very controlled kakash did
throw everything at him but
unfortunately it just wasn't enough
Hikaru in top form yeah and then three
wins for Arjun Eric icy against the
other teenager Ali Reza Borussia to win
that match Wesley Seoul getting that one
game win he needed to knock Ralph
momento down to the losers bracket and
let's take a look at the bracket double
elimination format this season on the
Champions chess tour means Magnus
Carlson stays on the winners bracket to
face Arjun arigaisy in the winners
semi-finals tomorrow Wesley so and
Hikaru Nakamura and the other winners
semi-finals also to be played tomorrow
that is best out of four rapid games on
the losers bracket Serana against
farusha that is best out of two rapid
games and momedov against gukesh
started to Rapid games I have to ask you
Robert Wesley so against Hikaru Nakamura
American battle you do hold us a
favorites in that one I think it's a
complete toss-up I know that's a cop-out
it's a cliche but Wesley so is so
difficult to beat and for a car Nakamura
if he's thinking about that semi-finals
loss at the global Championship that
could kind of make him feel like he
needs to win lose some objectivity so I
really see that both players having
their chances they've had impressive
days today hikara played the better
chess but tomorrow is a new one yeah and
then Tanya Arjun Eric icy he was crushed
by Magnus Carlsen and the final of the
Julius bear generation Cup last season
but he must have so much confidence
going into that semi-finals against
Magnus tomorrow 100 and also the fact
that he made it to the finals of the
Julius bad generation cup that is a huge
deal as well and I think it's going to
be very critical for Arjun to just
forget that he's playing Magnus and try
to keep that aside he needs to keep
control on the clock make sure that he
doesn't fall a lot below a lot behind
Magnus come up with some good opening
ideas he needs to do everything right
because that's what you need to do if
you have to beat Magnus yeah
that is one of the winner semifinals
tomorrow the other one
Wesley so against the car not come
around we're joined by Wesley
congratulations on winning your first
match of the Season Wesley
hi thank you very much it's uh good to
see you guys again very good to see you
two sitting at home in Minnesota I can
see Wesley what has today been like
sorry what has today been like in your
match against Ralph mamadol
oh it's been pretty tough I think Ralph
uh came to the match very well prepared
especially in the opening uh I didn't
get anything in game one but I almost
managed to Swindle him and he came to
his surprise me in the opening but I
applied pretty solidly and great game 3
was clearly the turning point because I
preferred this line in the king's Indian
but he didn't know what to do but I
blundered upon on beaten after that uh I
guess black had the initiative
but I was able to outplay him in the end
game
but that was nice and and game four was
pretty safe I guess
how do you feel about uh going into
matches being a big favorite like you
were today Wesley are you comfortable
being named the big favorite
well I don't think that was a big
favorite I think maybe I'm the favorite
but in a Four game match uh anything can
happen
and
they're off played really well
so you know I mean it's nice to
it's nice to play a good match today and
be able to push it through but
I mean of course tomorrow I'll have a
half opponent and Hikaru
and I'm sure he'd want to have uh hit
the wrench from the global chess
championship
a few months ago yeah so it's going to
be going to be interesting uh
I think today I was able to get some
positions that I like
and I was able to push it through
and Wesley uh well done uh on today's
match of course uh it's great to see you
back on the tour what are your goals for
this season and what do you think of the
new format
thank you yeah I I think
I I think I uh you know knew already
what my goals for this season is
we had we had that thing
but uh
yeah you remember my ghost wait but but
it's nice I mean
it seems that there's new rules a new
format within every year but I like the
time control with the three second
increment and I like I like much formats
even though I would prefer it to be six
games or eight games
but uh it's all it's all good at the
same time there are
far less events this year the the than
last year only six
after it's going to be a
it's going to be interesting I hope to
do well tomorrow because I was watching
the play in the other day and so
difficult to qualify in the top six so
uh I you know I hope to
do well and if I don't qualify then just
do the play in but it's going to be
interesting with lots of new players and
lots of grand Masters uh this year and
it's it's certainly tougher than
laughing yeah I remember I'm very
pleased also to be seated for the first
event and playing the same event as
Magnus
I remember one of your goals Wesley was
to win one of these Champions Chester
events this season what chances do you
give yourself in this one with both
Magnus in here uh he calls that you will
face tomorrow
yeah I I you know I mean I'm hoping that
one of them would uh fall early but it
didn't happen but uh
no I just you just want to play good
Chef I mean I'm still trying to focus on
classical chess this year
but uh but I like playing this uh
playing this online events I like this
format I'm
not the best player in Blitz uh there
are many other better players than me
but with 15 plus three I think I can I
can compete
and Wesley congratulations so much on
today's win it was amazing to see you
fight the difficult third game and do
your thing in the fourth one uh so
firstly congratulations and I want to
just look ahead to tomorrow and ask you
a little more about that because it's
such a big match for us it's sort of
like the two big heavyweights playing
against each other you're facing Hikaru
tomorrow what do you think you have to
do well to get by uh tomorrow's match
and is that something that you're
worried about what Hikaru brings to the
board that you need to watch out for
well first of all I have to understand
the format so tomorrow is just a four
game match yes
okay just a four game match winner
semi-final and yeah it's best out of
four uh rapid games just like today
okay so so it's it's nice uh
yeah I mean hiko's been doing very well
online uh winning speeches Championship
all those uh title Tuesdays so
you know I I think I have to be at my
very best to compete against him even
the match in Toronto could have could
have gone really either way
so uh
you know Hitler plays online every day
basically and he's got no one of the
highest ratings in chess.com
uh I think I need to get you know good
positions out the opening positions that
I enjoy playing and
try not to blunder anything and try to
keep up and
keep up on the clock uh today my time
management was not the best and I'm also
very impressed by the fact that you know
hikar won today in in three games and so
I'm going to be checking that and uh
hopefully
you know
hopefully history repeats itself like
from before yeah
what a match it's gonna be we're already
looking forward to it uh Wesley big
congratulations on your match win today
and good luck tomorrow as well
yeah thank you guys thank you so much
for joining us
Wesley so one out of four winners today
who stays on the winners bracket
tomorrow he will play Hikaru Nakamura
and we're gonna announce another winner
one of you guys at home who shared a
selfie on Twitter
and here we have the winner it is
D is it yeah watching from work with my
party
popper Hopper I was gonna say pooper
cheering for Wesley PS would love to
know my workplace air quality well Mike
now you can we're gonna send an air
things device to you is going to be
signed by Magnus Carlsen and you can use
it to measure air quality in your home
air quality has been good in the studio
today it's been the very first day of
the Champions chess tour 2023 season
good it's been amazing we've seen some
of the best players in the Chess World
kind of crush some of the up starts in
the Chess World and then we also saw
some mesmerizing finishes Wesley so kept
us on the edge of our seat he makes it
through the semis to face off against
the car Nakamura that'll be really
exciting tomorrow yeah and tomorrow we
will lose the first two players David
two players on the losers bracket they
will lose their matches and be knocked
out what do you expect from day two of
their thanks monsters I think any player
who is at risk of going out will want to
go out in style and I expect more of the
same those in the losers bracket they're
shorter matches just two games but I
expect more of the same today everyone
was going for the full point in every
battle and uh yeah I can't wait to see
more I'm so excited and we have to
remind you guys there is also a division
two and division three going on in the
air things Masters I'm just quickly
taking a look at some results the Neil
dubov has lost his match and it's
knocked down to the losers bracket in
division two you can check all of those
results if you headed to chess.com and
join us again tomorrow for day two of
the air things Master as the action
continues and two players will be
knocked out thank you so much for
watching today and we'll see you again
tomorrow bye for now
foreign
[Music]
thank you
energy
box
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]